foreign
[Music]
members take your seats please
how are you
here are you doing all right today
exactly
thank you
[Music]
foreign
the house will come to water members
take your seats
terrorization
and turn on your voting stations
the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne who was at
the house adjourned from the session of
May 18 2023. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed any of the eyes have it
and the house is adjourned the house
will attend to a Prayer by guest
chaplain the member from Exeter The
Honorable Alexis Simpson
thank you Mr
good morning colleagues and guests it is
good to be together here today
let us pray
o Divine comforter we come today with
heavy hearts for our colleague
representative janvrin who has recently
lost his son
we pray today that you will provide
comfort care and strength to him to the
entire janvin family to their friends
and to their whole community
and please continue to show us how to be
a community of compassion for him in the
upcoming months and years
as we all turn our hearts and our minds
to the work of the legislature today
please give us the ability to carry out
our work in the midst of the challenges
of day-to-day life
Center us this morning as we join our
hearts in an Interfaith adaptation of
the prayer attributed to Saint Francis
source of all that is Holy make me an
instrument of your peace
where there is hatred let me so love
where there is injury
pardon
where there is doubt faith
where there is despair
hope
where there is sadness Joy
and where the Shadows Fall may we still
find warmth
o Divine One grant that I may not so
much seek to be consoled as to console
to be understood
as to understand
to be loved as to love
for it is in giving that we receive
it is in pardoning that we are pardoned
and it is in caring for the vulnerable
that we find purpose
amen
Gia recognizes the member of the Hudson
representative John ulery who lead us in
the Pledge of Allegiance
ready
for a while
chair recognizes the elverne high school
being Naturals from Hudson who will now
sing on national anthem
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and the rock is
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives hatch and Siebert the
day important business Representatives
Bickford Catherine Harvey Paul Tunisian
Mason Mark Pearson and tatrov
these leaves will be granted unless
otherwise by the house
will attend the introduction of guests
Mr Speaker please welcome 4th grade
students from Wheelock Elementary School
guests of the Keen delegation they are
with us in the gallery today
welcome to New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will attend away communication
Mr Speaker in a letter dated May 31st
2023 dear Paul please be advised that
the following representative elect was
sworn into office by the governor in
Council on this day Hillsborough County
District 3 Mark W plamonden sincerely
David M Scanlon Secretary of State
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will now attend to the consent
calendar
Mr Speaker from the committee on
Election law cacr-9 removed by
Representatives philia Stephen Smith
Ellen Reed germana Newell Aaron Harley
Sellers spelane and Doucet
from the committee on executive
departments and administration Senate
Bill 107 removed by Representatives
Carol McGuire groda shuitt Simon Fred
Davis Tony leckis post Gerhard Alicia
leckis and Dan McGuire
are there any other bills removed from
the consent calendar
representative Wiseman moves at the
consent calendar with the relevant
amendments as printed in the day's house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed eyes have it in the
consent calendar is adopted house will
attend to the regular calendar
be happy
on criminal justice and Public Safety
tuitions referred Senate Bill 58 and act
relative to arrest without a warrant
while in care of the medical profession
on the premises of a residential care or
Health Care Facility instead of the same
report the same with the following
Amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment Senator
David Muse for the majority of the
committee
the committee amendment is
1490h printed in house record 27 Pages
28 through 29. are you ready for the
question on the committee Amendment all
those in favor say aye
there's a close nay the eyes have it and
the committee amendment is adopted
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment
representative Heinz person of Hines
here
office floor Amendment one eight three
four h printed in house record 27 Pages
29-30 chair recognizes representative
Heinz
do you recognize representative Heinz at
speed
thank you uh I believe this amendment is
good uh improves upon the underlying
bill
sorry
thank you uh I believe this amendment is
good improves upon the underlying bill I
believe there are some problems with
with this belt so I'd ask for your
support thank you
do you recognize your representative Roy
um thank you Mr Speaker I don't know
what he just said but whatever it was is
wrong please
please vote against that
his Defiance has requested a division
this will be a division vote numbers
take your seats
okay
the house will come to order
this is going to
it's going to be division vote
chair recognizes
representative Roy for a parliamentary
inquiry
Mr Speaker if I don't know what this
amendment does I probably would not vote
for it neither should you please vote
red thank you
the motion before us was the Heinz floor
Amendment 1834h this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your post or press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
thank you
foreign
43 voting a 323 voting a the amendment
fails
bills on second reading open to further
Amendment
representative Manion offers floor
1835h printed in house record 27 page
30.
chair recognize representative mannion
to speak to his Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker
this amendment looks to clarify the
situations where warrantless arrests are
permitted under the committee Amendment
the committee Amendment mentions actual
or threatened violence and this
amendment changes that language to
specifically reference statutes for
assault domestic violence and criminal
threatening
further the committee Amendment broadly
Scopes the justifiable scenario for
arrests to include interfering with
quote services that that a licensed
Medical Professional has determined to
be medically necessary
what we've learned over the last couple
years is that medically necessary is
much more of a moving gold post than
you'd assume
this amendment will clarify that by
by more appropriately referencing
statute for emergency care I believe
expanding the authority of police to
make warrantless arrests as dangerous to
Liberty and adding text to this section
of RSA should be extremely precise
and only when absolutely necessary
please support this amendment by
pressing the green button thank you
gee I recognize representative Roy
thank you Mr Speaker and and thank you
to the previous speaker for a cogent
argument
um
what this bill does
and unfortunately I have to take this
very seriously one of our one of our own
members isn't here today because of the
situation that this bill brings up
representative agent
what this bill does
is if you assault or threaten violence
in a hospital
and it interrupts medically necessary
care you can be arrested when the police
get there
now the interrupts necessary care I put
in there to protect citizens that means
if you're in the waiting room and
someone says hey put your mask on and
you say make me put my mask on you can't
be arrested because you're not
interrupting Medical Care you have to be
interrupting Medical Care necessary in
medical care
to be arrested under the statute as it
stands now you can be getting treated
punch your doctor in the nose
the police can get there they can't do a
darn thing they have to go get a warrant
come back and by federal law they still
have to treat you they can't kick you
out of the hospital
all this does is let the police get
there and say when you're finished being
cared for you are under arrest and it
protects the hospital we have left our
our medical providers hanging in the
wind during covert they were Heroes and
now we don't even want to protect them
we need to do what we can but I agree
not giving too much power the original
Bill we got from the Senate had the
ability of a hospital janitor to hold
you until the police got there and that
was ridiculous we tuned this down as far
as we could go
to still allow the police to protect the
Medical Care Professionals
and not let citizens be unnecessarily
held or their Liberties interrupted
again it has to be
interrupting necessary medical care that
means not at the front door not in the
waiting room not anything else unless
you interrupt someone picture one of
your family members this is in a car
accident and your child is getting
service in the Next Room and the doctor
can't tend to them because some drunk
has punched a doctor in the face
would you want them arrested I would
thank you I ask you to support the as is
thank you
emotion support the bill
vote red the motion before us is the
floor Amendment one eight three five h
uh are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
and those have it floor Amendment fails
the motion before us now is ought to
pass with Amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
Mr Close nay
the eyes haven't committee report is
adopted
Amendment
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred Senate Bill 213
act relative to educational institution
policies on social media having
considered the same what the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation to build a lot of paths
with Amendment Senator Rick lad for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Valerie McDonald from the minority of
the committee committee amendment is
2061h printed in house record 27 page
51. question is on the amendment all
those in favor of the amendment say aye
the eyes have in the committee of
members had adopted the motion before us
now was ought to pass with Amendment the
chair recognizes representative Belcher
thank you Mr Speaker and good morning
colleagues
I've taken the unusual step this morning
of signing up to be a second speaker on
a bill and against this bill
uh something I hope to not make a habit
of but I feel very strongly about this
bill and you need to hear why
first of all we did hear rather we did
have a subcommittee on this bill we
entertained and heard expert testimony
on this bill
we heard that this bill which modifies
the language and existing law to exempt
certain social media uses and platforms
from the definition of social media such
that they can be brought in as parts of
classes in our Public Schools
so we heard that this bill will subject
students
to the potential danger of private
messages enabling Predators potentially
contact students
we heard from the standpoint of data and
privacy that there could in fact be
breaches of student data and privacy and
there is no real recourse because this
bill is particularly aimed at one
platform
the LinkedIn platform though it could
apply to any platform but Microsoft
owning the LinkedIn platform will not
negotiate a data agreement we have to go
with a standard data agreement which
waives basically all of all of the
students rights
finally as far as the major problems
here this bill would Place students
within the context of their Public
School classes under the terms of
service of third-party social media that
includes speech codes and codes that can
restrict freedom of Association it would
subject them to any number of punitive
things that could interrupt their
coursework and I'd like to make a couple
points just from very recent history in
the news that really articulate this
point first of all the LinkedIn platform
kicked off the third major GOP Contender
for the Republican presidency primary
two weeks ago removed from their
platform for criticizing the Chinese
Communist Party
LinkedIn has been linked to federally
sponsored censorship in coordination
with the state department
finally just yesterday our governor
issued an executive order regarding the
negative effects social media has on the
mental health of minors
there's no need for this bill
the
the items the badges that they can
access through social media are not
industry recognized credentials they
don't do anything to certify you as
capable of doing a job they're simply
quizzes that you take online that if
they desire to they can certainly do
from home they do not need to be a part
of any classroom study
and finally the things that they do need
to access in the classroom through
digital platforms that are not social
media they can already access under
existing law
there is no upside to this bill it is
all downside I would ask you to protect
freedom of speech and Association for
schools and students
by voting no
or uh yes by voting though and allowing
another motion to be made thank you
chair recognizes representative McDonald
thank you Mr Speaker and I Echo the
remarks of my colleague from wakefields
my professional social media accounts
have had not one not two but three false
suspensions and within the past few
weeks have been impersonated twice
this means someone is pretending to be
me
partly due to these recent events I am
speaking today
because it takes someone of my
generation to protect those even younger
from falling victim to harmful predators
Senate Bill 213 fails to recognize that
child safety is Paramount instead
students would be subjected to the whims
of Technology manufacturers
completely outside the Realms of
Education
school districts are unable to negotiate
with third-party social media platforms
as a result
students are subjected to terms of
service that can change at any moment
updates could limit speech by penalizing
students for ideological beliefs causing
the loss of job prospects and further
consequences
adolescents who are still determining
personal ideologies should not fear
unemployment for current violations of
third party terms of service yet to
exist
proving to be a gateway to the Future
New Hampshire's Career and Technical
education courses have allowed high
school students to take part in programs
of study leading to Industry recognized
credentials
these students are more competitive job
applicants with lower rates of
unemployment and higher job satisfaction
Senate Bill 213 hinders the successful
CTE model by inhibiting students from
obtaining these credentials
stunting Granite State Ingenuity and
compromising student privacy
at no point is teacher student or parent
consent required before unauthorized
users can interact with children's
profiles
in other words data cannot be protected
from unwanted access and school
districts have limited ability to
intervene even when students safety is
jeopardized
so if it were to become law Senate Bill
213 would needlessly harm children
I implore you my distinguished
colleagues to join me in voting against
the motion thank you
I recognize representative Ladd
thank you Mr Speaker
213 was a very controversial bill in the
education committee
and you've heard the minority present
that position
the language which we have as amended
there are three primary points in the
amendment
and the language has been approved by
legal staff at the Department of
Education
first question we have is shall not
shall social media
not apply to platforms used for
demonstrating evidence in student career
development
so our Career Technical educations
centers staff directors Etc able to use
social media as an instrument to help
students receive these industry
recognized credentials which we hope all
our students are leaving Career
Technical education with the curriculum
in these centers is aligned with
industry now
industry is posting all this on social
media
we're looking at areas such as
engineering Automotive Health Sciences
construction culinary all the services
provided through our Center
and instruction leads to as I said
before these recognized credentials so
students leave with a job in hand a good
paying job at that
so why do we need the social media
when I was looking at social media today
in terms of my grandson who is taking
courses this summer at talk business
school as an internship I had to work
through Linkedin to get there
and so access to Industry standards is
now available on these sites LinkedIn is
a business and employment focused social
media platform platform platform
primarily used for professional
networking and career development and
allows students to post their
credentials and employers to post jobs
and vacancies where these students are
looking
the question arises
should a young adult enrolled in a CTE
program be provided the opportunity to
obtain an industry recognized credential
by using a social media platform and who
makes this decision
the second part to the amendment deals
with
some of the issues that the minority
presented
it says written permanent parental
permission must be attained by the CTE
Center in order for a student to be on
the platform written parental permission
not the state saying you can't get on
who is responsible who has the rights
for that education we've debated this on
this floor many a Time
I believe parents have the right to say
yay or nay
not the state and not somebody else in
this house right here
I believe firmly in parental rights
and there was a discussion about freedom
of speech freedom of thought freedom of
choice
if we don't pass this bill we're
impinging upon that freedoms that the
family is able to make now thirdly in
the amendment
technology platforms and services used
by students at the CTE Center must be
part of the students approved program of
study
that means they can't use that platform
at all unless it's part of that program
and there at the school at that time the
student is working on it with that
director or the instructor
the Lea plans every local Education
Agency has to have a policy in place
regarding data personal privacy and use
of these platforms and that's a
requirement that every District must
have so it's a local control issue and
they are working on this with a
Consortium amongst all the school
districts
so in summary
guard rails have been put in place
for use of any online platform while
you're at school
platforms must be approved as part of
the approved program of study
parental permission
opt in not opt out opt-in that means a
written form has to be signed by parent
for a student to use this while in that
CTE course
the amendment has been approved by two
attorneys
at the Department of Education
it's been requested by our CTE directors
by our staff by the CT advisory Council
by various businesses
we need these folks to come out of
schools with a credential a certificate
in hand
and by doing this with a supervisor at
school there's less opportunity for a
student to get into trouble
and get in somewhere that's not safe
rather than doing it home alone
reality high school students are already
using these platforms this amendment
tightens online platform use in
accordance with the pro programs that we
have in the school district or we have
in statute here
so it is a local control issue
and this amendment only carves out one
exception and that's for a Career
Technical education
and we need more students more people in
the state coming out prepared for this
the careers
that we need filled in this state right
now so please support this bill by
pressing the green button thank you
a division has been requested members
take your seats
Mr Speaker
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
the motion before us is majority
committee report of autopass has amended
on Senate bill 213. this is going to be
a roll call vote care recognized
representative cortello for a
parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker
if I believe that schools should not be
promoting the usage of social media
especially considering the recently
issued executive order by the governor
which addresses the negative impacts of
such online Outlets
if I know that this bill
does not sufficiently address safety
concerns such as data privacy and online
Predators while it does expose students
to arbitrary third-party terms of
service
if I know that Career and Technical
education programs can provide the
industry recognized credentials that
students need to be successful in their
future careers without having to use
social media platforms such as LinkedIn
would I now press the red button and
protect students from the negative
aspects of social media platforms thank
you Mr Speaker
Geo recognized representative Cornell
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know as a two-term member of the Career
and Technical education advisory Council
that this bill has been requested by
potential employers such as the
hospitality and auto Industries numerous
times
and if I know that the parental opt-in
language ensures that parents and
custodial caregivers of students under
the age of 18 are aware of data and
privacy protocols used by districts when
students use digital platforms
and if I know that virtual or electronic
resumes in the form of online portfolios
are the industry standard for job
Seekers and that access to these
platforms including those with
assessments leading to credentials is an
essential component of the career
development work that New Hampshire High
School students ought to be able to
easily access and finally if I know that
this bill came out of the education
committee with bipartisan support I ask
you to join me and push the green button
to pass this bill that is good for both
students and businesses thank you the
motion before us is the majority
committed report of water passes amended
on Senate bill 213. it's a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
all members president an opportunity to
vote household 10 say the vote
21 voting a 175 voting a committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on Election
law to which was referred
Senate Bill 70 FN enact relatively
establishment of an election
informational portal considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation of Bill or
the password Amendment it's in Ross
Berry for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that as in
expedient to legislate Senator Claudine
Burnham for the minority of the
committee
committee amendment is
1280h printed in house record 27 pages
36-27
chair recognizes representative Lane
it was in a lane to speak against the
amendment
chair recognize representative Barry
if you don't have a debate on the
amendment
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
opposite
do you guys have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question before and of course now is
the majority committee report of water
pass as amended not Senate Bill 70. are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
Mr post nay
the eyes have it committee report is
adopted
house will be in order
majority committee on environment
agriculture which was referred Senate
Bill 61 relative to surface water
setbacks for landfills having considered
the same report the same following
Amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment
Senator Peter Bixby for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee
have been considered the same being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative Linda Askins for the
minority of the committee
the amendment is
1979h printed in house record 27 Pages
34 through
36.
this is going to be a division vote on
the amendment members take your seats
please
the motion before is
is amendment 1979h
this is a division vote chair recognizes
representative Virgo for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this
amendment makes minimal changes to SB 61
but increases the cost to the taxpayer
from a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to two hundred thousand dollars
would I now uh would if I know that and
Mr Speaker if I know the amendment
is the increase in the amendment is for
a third party contractor consultancy to
advise the Department of Environmental
Sciences are
services our highly trained
professionals that are Adept at doing
this uh to to help them do their work to
advise them and how to do their job and
finally Mr Speaker if I know that
there's another amendment a better
Amendment coming after this would I now
press the red button to defeat this
amendment thank you Mr Speaker
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know this committee
Amendment passed with bipartisan support
in the environment and agriculture
committee
and Mr Speaker if I further know that
this amendment makes SB 61 a much better
bill by adding in RFP conflict of
interest language and an extension
period for new DES rules to be adopted
instead of reverting back to current
rules for citing landfills and Mr
Speaker if I also know that we worked
hard on language that would be
acceptable to Des the folks on the other
side of the wall and other parties
involved in crafting this legislation so
that it can be that it can advance in
the legislative process would I now
press the green button and vote to adopt
this committee Amendment thank you Mr
Speaker
the motion before us is committee
Amendment 1979 H this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
a 61 voting a the committee amendment is
adopted bills on second reading open to
further Amendment Senator Potenza office
floor Amendment 2167
is recognized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker being a new
legislator the process of getting to
this point was quite disappointing I
know the environment and agricultural
committee has been down the setbacks for
landfills road with several bills over
the last few years the most recent was
HB 56 that was overwhelmingly passed by
this body 244 to 155 but was
subsequently itl by the other side of
the wall
the pressure coming in to do something
now feels like a fire burning that needs
to be put out not to be confused with
the three Solid Waste facilities that
were on fire over the past few weeks in
New England let's be clear that we were
told by the experts at DES that a new
landfilled in New Hampshire will not be
needed for at least 20 years maybe 30 or
more with the food waste in composting
initiatives and solutions that are
finally coming to fruition in New
Hampshire
why is there such an urgency to push
through a bill that is inherently flawed
that is the million dollar question for
which I believe we can all conclude the
answer my Amendment fixes many of the
critical red flags in SB 61.
our committee witnessed incredible
disrespect from unelected unaccounted
unaccountable bureaucrats threatening
vetoes if there were any changes made to
SB 61 and one gentleman from the agency
saying his stakeholder was the governor
the time money and energy to run for
state representative and to subsequently
be elected and serve to then watch a
bill get pushed through which removes
legislative oversight and Authority was
what brought me here
I haven't slept I've worked on this for
for weeks our stakeholders are the
citizens of New Hampshire that put their
trust in us to make sure that unelected
bureaucrats and Industry Gatekeepers
aren't making laws that we were elected
to do for the real stakeholders that's
the citizens of New Hampshire
would we Outsource the determination of
a state speed limit to a private
consultant we all know the answer to
that question there's also some
constitutional questions that come into
play with SB 61 because the general
court is not allowed to delegate their
Authority
uh to another body as well as there's
some taxation without representation
implications as well
sb61 is based on the false premise that
there is more science to study here
there is plenty of controversy but all
of the science on this specific topic is
actually settled SB 61 outsources a
fully legislative policy and that
responsibility to a private consultant
this amendment changes my Amendment
changes so that this study gets reported
back to the legislature
during our committee meeting this
amendment was introduced and received a
vote bipartisan of 10 to 10. there were
four absences on the committee that day
so one can assume that if this amendment
would have received more support as the
previous Amendment did I rise in strong
support of the the minor but critical
changes my amendment makes to SB 61. our
constituents only want clean water and
non-toxic living environments for
themselves and their families
many of these constituents have
diligently and respectfully contacted
our committee been in attendance at
committee meetings and have considerable
and diverse expertise on this subject
why did SB 61 exclude people in the
study that had other expertise than a
thicker piece of plastic wrap will do
the trick
maybe ones that might show greater
forethought than the new Titanic is
better than the old because we wrapped
the new one in plastic
this amendment puts environmental
science back in the room with the
industry related Engineers to execute a
study which will help Direct Des
in the rule making
in the rulemaking for news site-specific
setback rules all with keeping a Smart
Balance of respecting industry needs and
the health and well-being of New
Hampshire citizens
my Amendment also helps to rule out
undue technocratic bias the language
previously favored contracts that design
and construction that design and
construct landfills it is well known
that such firms invariably tilt towards
the conclusion that landfills are so
well engineered that it doesn't matter
where they are located to counteract
this bias my amendment requires that
contractors have experiences not only in
land landfill engineering and
hydrogeology but in also in identifying
and evaluating environmental and health
risks
this is critical because some
contractors put so much faith in the
power of Technology they fail to
adequately recognize the consequences of
Technology failure
the best contractor will be the one that
gives
due consideration to the limits of
landfill technology and the benefits of
equitably managing environmental risks
lastly and most importantly the number
two reason for my Amendment
the language in SB 61 which was not
changed in the previous Amendment
if the department does not adopt rules
in accordance with Section 3 and 4 of
this act within 24 months of the
effective date of this act the
department shall apply its current rules
applicable to surface water protection
in determining the required setback to
any application for such a standard
permit that is being held in advance
when such 24-month period expires and
approve it if it complies with current
rules
we were told that if we change this
specific language in the bill
it would be vetoed or killed by the
other body
why would we ever pass a bill that says
we are commanding a study that taxpayers
are going to pay for that study whether
it's 150 000 or 200 000 dollars
and
we the legislature have no oversight
once that said study is completed but if
after the study that we the people paid
for to help determine new rules if Des
doesn't adopt new rules in 24 months we
can go back to the old non-site specific
rules this is a circular firing squad
statement and completely rendered the
bill useless
my change was simple
if the department does not adopt rules
in accordance with section three and
four of this act within 24 months of the
effective date of this act the
department shall hold any application
for such a standard permit in a bands
until such rules are adopted
isn't it time to put Common Sense back
into an issue that will affect New
Hampshire citizens for decades centuries
to come
wasn't this what we were elected to do
it is time to be brave and make doing
the right thing popular again
thank you
chair recognizer Wendy Thomas
hi there I am representative Wendy
Thomas and I ask for your support on
this very important floor Amendment
sometimes it's not easy being a
legislator
we have to balance so many needs the
needs of our constituents the businesses
in the state the welfares of others and
sometimes we even have to balance what
those and other the in the other
branches of government want sometimes it
can be difficult
but sometimes it's very easy as it is in
the case of this amendment
when we know we are making a bill
stronger when we know that People's
Health and Welfare will benefit and when
we know that our environment will be
protected it's easy to do
in fact it's the reason why we are up
here
to make good law and to help protect
others
this amendment to SB 61 simply clarifies
some terms and conditions that have been
left so intentionally vague that if one
wanted to one could drive a truck maybe
even a garbage truck through them
when a bill as important as where to
place a landfill that will create toxic
leachate which could lead to
environmental contamination does not
consider all scientific or safety
concerns which are needed to provide
safety for the people who live near
there and the environment including
Wildlife then it's wrong
when the bill outsources site-specific
setback analysis to a currently unknown
consultant instead of performing it
in-house then Houston we have a problem
this bipartisan Amendment recognizes
those holes and defines vague
terminology and sets guard rails in
others
so what does this amendment do that the
previous Amendment does not
Federal Environmental laws generally
seek to protect Public Health with quote
an ample margin of safety
but SB 61 only seeks to protect New
Hampshire's Waters quote adequately
this amendment fixes that discrepancy on
page 2 line 27 and puts this bill in
line with Federal standards
on page 2 line 32 it defines the term
representative with travel time and its
variable across the site
this has been added because the previous
phrase representative in terms of
groundwater speed
without more definition of the actual
conditions is something that can
completely be determined by the
developer
on page three line four the amendment
changes a shall to a May one of our
favorite changes to make
as in the department may take into
account any measures proposed in the
application for a permit that would
provide greater or more redundant
production of perennial surface water
than the department would otherwise
require under its rules
this change gives Des the option to
consider or to not consider a proposal
or part of a proposal
page 3 line 20 lines 28 through 31 have
been changed to further Define the
permit application proposal and if the
department relies on those measures then
the department shall require
implementation of those measures as a
condition to any permit
this change simply ensures that Des
relies on measures and that those
measures are implemented in the process
we are asking the Department of
Environmental Services to walk their
walk
on page 4 lines six through nine there
is language that proposes a statement of
any potential conflicts of interest with
any entity that may benefit from any
change in setback requirements and that
any preference be given to proposals
that demonstrate the qualified
consulting firm or individuals have
credentials and experience in evaluating
the health
and safety risks associated with
Environmental Protections as well as the
engineering and hydrogeological aspect
of landfill design and sighting
this change has been made has been added
to make sure that the health and safety
risks are fully considered in all
aspects it also allows Des to consider
whether the consultant has expertise in
Environmental Protection
not only in landfill science
it makes sure that the right people are
the ones who are doing the job
page 4 lines 19-20 the term adequate is
again defined as protect perennial
surface water with an ample margin of
safety again this change brings the bill
to Federal standards
page four aligns 28-30 add the
recommendation that soil bedrock
proximity demographics or other factors
that would render a particular proposal
new land find site landfill site
absolutely unsuitable for development
other United States
have thriving landfill Industries
despite regulations that absolutely
forbid new landfills in super porous
sandy soil
this amendment asks the consultant to at
least consider whether similar
protections might make sense for New
Hampshire
all geological conditions must be
considered
page four aligns 31-36 continuing to
page five lines one and two the selected
contractor shall complete the assessment
and submit a final report to the Senate
energy and natural resources committee
and the house environmental and
agricultural committee making any
recommendations for legislation or
rulemaking to those committees within
150 days after contract approval
this is Perhaps Perhaps the biggest
change
the final report would not go to Des but
instead it would go to the Senate and
legislature so that we could use it to
make recommendations for legislation or
for rule making
this amendment also allows for public
comment
don't you think our constituents have a
thing or two to say about landfills
being located near large bodies of water
or near them in their communities
we know that landfills leak we know that
people can get sick from exposure to
these leachates
my town is living proof of this
without proper protections water gets
contaminated and people get sick
on page five line 14 there is removal of
the 24-month Restriction after the
effective date of this act and on page 5
line 24 through 25 there is a
stipulation that the department shall
hold any application for such a standard
permit in advance until such rules are
adopted
these changes were added because it just
makes sense why proceed before you have
definite rules
okay so why are all these seemingly
nitpicky changes being made it's because
we can't mess around with this folks
this bill is about where landfills which
are piles and piles of potentially toxic
garbage are going to be located and we
have to make sure that the people who
are making the decision receive fair
unbiased and scientific information on
any proposed locations
we also need to make sure that the
people environment and Wildlife are
fully considered in this very important
decision look garbage is a way of life
and until we change that we will need
landfills however these landfills must
be placed where they can do the least
harm to communities and our environment
the house already passed a perfectly
good bill that would have solved this
landfill citing problem however in the
branch across the wall they turn this
into a study fine if you want to study
then let's have a study however
toxic runoff and leachate from landfills
is quite frankly a danger and a threat
to public and environmental safety we
must put in the proper guideline
guardrails to ensure that every possible
point is considered
let's make sure that that's that that
study is well defined and well thought
out and that the process is fair and
complete
let's give the Senate and the governor
the study they want but let's make sure
it directs the Consultants to report to
us
the legislature for our consent or
modification
this amendment does that it lets us do
our job
I urge you to support this well thought
out and bipartisan Amendment which puts
the guard rails in place that are needed
when considering where to place
potentially toxic and health and
environmental altering landfills in our
beautiful state of New Hampshire thank
you
chair recognize representative jermaina
thank you Mr Speaker I rise today
admittedly reluctant in my support and
I'll explain why my support is is
somewhat reluctance we've heard a lot we
know a lot already about how we got to
this point we had a perfectly good bill
that had specific setback rules that we
passed in this house with broad
bipartisan support it was killed on the
other side of the wall
we received SB 61
one of the greatest virtues I think one
of the things that made me want to work
as hard as we could to get this bill
through is the importance of the
abeyance a two-year abeyance while the
rule writing process took place I tried
really hard
I know that everyone on our committee
did
I have great admiration and respect for
our leadership on both sides of the
aisle in our committee for all of the
efforts that were made with all of the
various stakeholders to make a bill that
wasn't very good quite frankly a bad
bill for the people of the State of New
Hampshire better unfortunately at the
very last hearing that we had
there were a couple of straws that broke
that camel's back and in the end I
concluded that I could not support the
bill as written and I want to share with
you just two reasons among many
why in the end I cannot support the bill
is written and uh I rise today in
support of this amendment they've both
been referred to before so I won't go
into detail but the first is is an
important change of language that the
bill is written contains reference to
adequate protections for bodies of water
we wanted to have based on Expert
testimony we wanted that language change
to language that reflects the Clean
Water Act which calls for an ample
margin of safety
we were told that that was a no-go that
change of language ample margin of
safety by the industry that this bill is
supposed to regulate we were told was a
no-go
likewise
the language that my colleague just
referred to about representative travel
time of groundwater
we want it that's that's a pretty vague
word representative I could drill 10
times or 50 times in a 50 Fair 50 square
foot plot where I know I'm going to get
the readings I want and I can submit
that as being representative of the site
we ask that wording be changed that
would refer to
um
variation across the site so that you
would have to drill in lots of different
places across that site and get
scientific data that was genuinely
representative of the site not
cherry-picked data again we were told by
the industry that is supposed to be
regulated by this legislation that that
was a no-go
and that was the straw that broke the
camel's back for me
we have a rule writing process that is
going forward and I sincerely hope that
my colleagues whom I admire whom I
respect whose hard work I'm grateful for
I sincerely hope that they're right that
the oversight that this committee has
the authority to do
the oversight that it is our
responsibility to do during the rule
writing process I hope that we can use
that oversight in order to make sure
that the industry does not have the same
power to influence the rule writing
process that they clearly have had in
the writing of legislation
unfortunately based on what I've seen
I've absolutely no confidence that that
would happen
the hiring of a consultant to do produce
a report we all understand how that can
work if any of you have been attending
some of the public sessions about the
current 306 rule writing process that's
a process which is clearly driven toward
a predetermined outcome
and the result in the end will not be
reflective of the needs and the
interests of the people that we were
elected to represent
so I I understand that if we adopt this
amendment the reality is in all
likelihood that it's going to be killed
on the other side of the wall or it's
going to be killed in the coroner office
and that's why I'm really reluctant
to support this but I can no longer
accept the idea that some Bill any Bill
even this bill is better than no bill
so I rise today to ask all of you to
support this amendment
to make this bill reflective of the
interests and the needs of the people in
the state of New Hampshire thank you Mr
Speaker I recognize representative Aaron
speaker
this floor amendment that is before us
while well-intentioned
will ultimately kill this much needed
bill
the amendment contains many impediments
to SB 61's passage it was not
constructed with an eye to get
coordinated support from the folks on
the other side of the wall or Des or any
other interested parties
and you and I know that when we do these
bills we do work together with a lot of
people
that's the way it works
it comes before us today placed in your
seat Pockets without really being fully
reviewed or vetted and furthermore this
amendment contains language which is too
restrictive to the process of
establishing new DES landfill citing
rules
the amendment before you seeks to make
finding a suitable third party to
perform a study more restrictive and
will surely limit the pool of applicants
this bill Amendment will also draw out
this process of rulemaking for landfill
citing out in a manner which is unending
this amendment has no real tide table
because of the rule making process is
not completed in two years then any
permits held in abeyance can wait
indefinitely until new rules are
established this is an open-ended
process that can essentially go on
forever and forever is not a good plan
the minority feels SB 61 is written and
amended by the committee doesn't go far
enough to ensure Public Safety regarding
landfill citing
this is simply not true because the
original Bill and its committee
Amendment will definitely help create
improvements in our current 30 year old
rules additionally Des has told us that
they need assistance in performing the
kind of analysis required to do the
technical groundwork and research to
create better and more technically
robust landfill citing rules the
original bill and the committee
Amendment already accomplishes that
this amendment before you if passed
will certainly not be acceptable moving
on to the next step
and if this bill dies then it is
guaranteed that nothing will get done
this year with regard to meaningful
legislation for landfill citing rule
adoption SB 61 is written and amended by
the committee is a good bill on its own
and will provide Des with the much
needed expertise and assistance
to update Des landfill citing rules
finally
the rules for citing landfills in New
Hampshire are set to expire next year
SB 61 with the amendment passed by our
committee will assist Des to re-examine
its rules regarding landfill setbacks in
an efficient and expedient manner
we must not lest this chance get
slipping away by adding in amending
language that will ensure the death of
this bill
I implore you to reject this floor
Amendment and pass the underlying Bill
and committee Amendment which is much
needed and has already been vetted by
many parties thank you so much for
listening
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of Auto pass was
amended on Senate bill 61.
the question is on the floor the Potenza
floor Amendment
2167.
who requested a division since requested
a division this will be a division vote
remember
Jonah
representative wheeler requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
[Music]
the motion before us is floor Amendment
this is a roll call vote
chair recognized representative Haskins
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that environmental laws
generally seek to protect Public Health
with an ample margin of safety
but SB 61 only seeks to protect New
Hampshire's Waters adequately
further if I know that 61 does not
require the Department of Environmental
Services to even consider
whether a
consultant hired to do this study has
expertise in Environmental Protection
not just landfill design
and if I know that 61 does not at least
ask the consultant to consider adverse
conditions for citing landfills such as
super porous soils which other states
have done and finally if I know that the
legislature which writes the laws to
protect Granite Staters
should exercise oversight over the study
including the right to review
question and comment on report
then would I press the green button and
vote for the floor amendment that
provides these assurances and
protections thank you Mr Speaker
I recognize representative Megan Murray
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
floor amendment is well intentioned and
highly protective but also creates an
open-ended rule writing process and if I
also know that many aspects of this
floor Amendment were summarily rejected
on the other side of the wall
and if I also know that in order to
prevent permits being issued under the
unacceptable 200-foot setback we need
the abeyance in SB 61 as written by the
committee to be passed and signed into
law would I vote no or read on this
floor Amendment thank you
the motion before is the floor Amendment
2167 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
to reupholster press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
representative Missouri I need your
votes
representative Gallagher
because I'm hungry
representative
ball Memphis president opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
152 voting day 226 voting a
the floor Amendment fails we're now on
to ought to pass as amended the chair
recognizer of Center verville
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker sorry for being a
little tardy
colleagues
I am going to strongly encourage you to
vote no on this bill
so this bill is calling for a third
party consultancy
to advise the Department of
Environmental Services
on rulemaking for landfill citing
Des is our highly trained professionals
that we hire and Trust to do this work
they are doing
this work
so what's the problem with getting a
Little Help From A consultancy other
than blowing two hundred thousand
dollars
the pro-industry side
is afraid that the consultancy is going
to be the Greenies
and that we're going to wreak havoc and
just put landfills wherever we want
willy-nilly in New Hampshire
the Greenies and I don't mean that in a
bad way
because I have a I have a green green
streak through me for sure
but if the Greenies control it the rules
are going to be written
so that it'll be virtually impossible to
cite a landfill anywhere in New
Hampshire
and we hear people bemoan we're
importing trash from out of state
and it's a travesty against New
Hampshire
so let me ask you a question
sorry let me ask you a question Mr
Speaker
where does our Hazmat go
where does our hazardous material go
it doesn't go into landfills
it doesn't go into Hazmat mitigation
facilities in New Hampshire
do you know why
because we don't have one
to the best of my knowledge most of it
goes to Ohio
where they have a high temperature
incinerator to dispose of such material
imagine if Ohio decided we're not going
to take New Hampshire's Hazmat anymore
that would be a problem
a serious problem not to mention it's
interstate commerce which is beyond the
purview of our control if we can't cite
landfills
then we export all of our rubbish
to some poor other state
that's not fair either
it's my opinion
that our current sighting rules
are adequate and sufficient
this is all carryover
from the Dalton landfill Casella
landfill hangover of a couple of years
ago that project has been
recalled right it's that that is no
longer on the table
this this bill is going to bite somebody
where they don't want to be bitten
and the best part of it is it's like
rolling the dice we don't know who it's
going to bite until after we pass it and
somebody else beyond our control hires
the consultancy that's going to drive
that bus
is there a stop Gap
sure there's a stop cap
Joe Carr those rules I assume go to gel
car
so is
is that where we want to have this fight
again
or
do we take a more rational reasonable
metered approach
and in trust the Department of
Environmental Services
to do that which they have been tasked
with
and it's interesting because as far as I
know and maybe somebody can bring
testimony to the contrary but the
Department of Environmental Sciences is
not asking in Services is not asking for
this
they're not asking for 200 000 to hire a
consultant they're quite confident they
can do their job without uh interference
from from the outside world
I say God bless them let's let's let
them do
the job that we've hired them to do let
us trust our highly trained professional
administrative staff to do their job
so
if you vote green
you're rolling the dice or flipping a
coin I guess
and so good luck to you me I'm voting
red
this bill has opposition from from every
angle right when when every everybody at
the table has a problem with a bill
that's not the bill to pass
right
so I I encourage you to listen to the
rest of the debate please consider what
what I've told you and when the time
comes vote red
wrote red
and kill this Bill thank you
chair recognize representative Bixby
thank you Mr Speaker
SB 61 deals with the rules for setbacks
between new landfills and surface water
bodies
tried to provide highly protective
guidance for the Department of
Environmental Services with HB 56 which
was itl'd on the other side of the wall
sb61 is the other body's approach to
setback rules and our committee has
amended it with a few improvements
as it came to us SB 61 gave Des two
years to make specific setback rules
based on site hydrology and Technical
measures that increa that increase
protection
and at the request of Des who said they
would not be able to do this uh in the
one year that they were that the other
body was originally thinking of but
required two years and that they would
not be able to do this without
additional Manpower in the form of a
consultant which is a short-term fix
rather than hiring new Personnel forever
uh and the the Des requested money for
the recall consultant in order to make
sure that they would be able to provide
to finish these rules in a timely manner
so another action another very important
aspect of SB 161 as it came to us is
that all all permits are held in the
bands until the rules are in place as
long as it happens within two years
our Amendment adds explicit language
that requires disclosure of conflict of
interest
provides a small increase in funding to
make sure that the RFP attracts a good
selection of well-qualified consultants
and allows for 90-day extension of the
abeyance in case of in extraordinary
circumstances that might prevent the
department from completing the rules in
within two years
if SB 6961 does not pass new landfill
permits a new landfill permit
applications can be filed almost
immediately and will be assessed under
the current completely unacceptable
200-foot setback
the committee amendment was negotiated
to strengthen the bill as much as
possible without inviting a vote of
non-concurrent on the other side of the
wall
we want to make sure
we wanted to make the bill more
protective but we were assured that more
stringent languages
would in fact cause the bill to fail
SB 61 as amended creates a clear process
for better rules and most critically it
stops all permit approvals within the
next two years please vote Yes on OTP to
protect our New Hampshire Waters thank
you
the motion before is the majority
committee report of Auto pass has
amended on Senate bill 61.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
division has been requested
nobody in that wasn't here
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of water passes amended
and Senate bill 61. this is a division
vote
the chair was unsure of the
yelling
if you're in favor you'll press the red
button I mean the green button if you're
imposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
thank you
[Music]
represent Newell
on
well Memphis president of the
opportunity to vote household 10 state
level
236 voting a 132 voting any committee
report is adopted
for what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker I would move that we remove
SB 149 regarding nurses agencies from
the table and I would request a division
vote
is any proper motion
is in a Weber moves that Senate Bill 149
be removed from the table
representative Sweeney has repressed the
roll call Will
is that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
the motion before us is to remove Senate
Bill 149 from the table
yeah
this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognized representative Moulton
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
discovered later that I had
misunderstood the effect of the bill and
if I want to have an opportunity to
support this bill and if I know this
would help our County nursing homes
would I now press the green button to
remove this bill from the table thank
you Mr Speaker chair recognizes
representative Carol McGuire for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill is well intentioned in trying to
deal with bad behavior on the part of
nursing agencies but is totally useless
and if I know that the registration it
requires is only a hassle it will not
prevent any of the abuses that the
proponents of this bill are
are in favor of they will still have to
deal with it
if I know that the problem it's trying
to solve is dealt with is the national
shortage of nurses while we have
high demand all over the country
and therefore if New Hampshire decides
to hassle the nursing agencies they'll
simply send their nurses to
Massachusetts or Maine or Vermont or
wherever it they can do it more easily
and if I know that despite the massive
power of the New Hampshire General Court
we cannot repeal the law of supply and
demand
what I now vote red to leave this this
bill on the table
the motion before us is to remove Senate
Bill 149 from the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
an opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
190 voting a 188 voting May the motion
passes senate senate Bill 149 is removed
from the table
we quit
for what reason is a member rise
Mr Speaker I'd like to make a motion to
print the marks from SB 61 in the
journal
it's not order we haven't finished the
debate yet
the motion before us now
is ought to pass as amended on Senate
bill 149.
do you recognize
chair recognize representative grassy
thank you Mr Speaker
first thing I'd like to point out that I
am not a nurse
but what I am is a member of the county
delegation in Stratford County
I'm a member of a county delegation as
you all are
one of our responsibilities as a member
of the county delegation is oversight of
our nursing homes
and as part of the oversight of our
nursing homes
all of you have care that our patients
get that are in those nursing homes
I had an opportunity to speak to my
nursing home administrator
and I want to tell you that all 10
nursing home administrators in the 10
counties in New Hampshire support this
bill
so we say it may not be needed but all
10 of them support it New Hampshire
Association of County sent you a notice
the other day saying they support this
bill as well
what we have to worry about what a
nursing home administrator has to worry
about when a nurse is planning to be out
sit for maternity or sick an injury or
whatever when they're shorted short a
staff
they have to depend on these nursing
agencies
these are they enter into contracts with
these nursing agencies to provide
replacements
so that our patients can receive quality
Care
the residents of our homes
receive quality Care
this bill does three things
requires that the medical staffing
agencies do business in New Hampshire be
registered with the state with the
officer professional licenses and
certification
it prohibits agencies from double
booking staff at multiple facilities
simultaneously and then engaging in a
bidding war between facilities at the
11th hour and rewarding the highest
bidder
and prohibits agencies of recruiting on
a provider's premises
sounds a little unethical but
when I spoke to particularly the part
where it talks about the double booking
I talked to my administrator and he said
you know when I get a call from an agent
we've entered into a contract and I get
a call from an agency and they said you
know that nursing is going to show up
this week because we got a better rate
from another
Another Place Another hospital or
another nursing home he says that sounds
like extortion they want me to pay more
than I agreed to
most of our budgets are set by us at the
counties and so they don't have the
ability to go out and just raise their
rates and and charge more money and dip
into the budget just get more money
they've come back to the delegations if
they need more money so this is creating
problems for them
and you know called it extortion and
that's exactly what it is it's extortion
and I think when you if you take a look
at it from what is our responsibility
to those folks our mothers our fathers
our relatives our parents our
grandparents who are in these homes
that we have to be concerned about the
quality of care
and when we're taking a look at the
issues that we have with Staffing and
retention right now in nursing homes
this is an important bill and this is
something that is valuable for us and we
should we should pass this bill today
so if I want to support our nursing home
support our nursing support the patients
who are in our nursing homes and support
our administrators who work hard to give
the best quality that we can in our
dirty homes what I not now vote green
and let's get this thing approved thank
you
I heard a request for a roll call
Senator Cushman requests a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
the motion before us is Senate Bill 149
ought to pass as amended this is a roll
call vote chair recognizer
representative McGuire Carol McGuire for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill merely requires registration of
nurse agencies
and if I know that the
office of professional licensure has
almost no control and no means to
discipline agencies that are
do not obey the rules or the laws other
than to unregister them
and if I know that that will be
ineffectual in solving the problems that
our nursing homes both County and
otherwise are facing and again if I know
we can't repeal the law of supply and
demand to get more nurses
and this bill will do nothing to solve
that problem would I press the red
button
do you recognize representative Weber
for a parliamentary
speaker if I know that the flight of
agencies and nurses to other states is
unlikely because they already have this
kind of registration in place
and this just levels the playing field
and if I want to give an even chance
especially to our County nursing homes
but to all of our institutions would I
now press the green button to pass this
bill
motion before us is auto pass is amended
on Senate Bill 149 it's a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button of your poster press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
thank you
[Music]
representative Perez
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the world
191 voting 887 voting a
Senate Bill 141 passes
for what reason does a member rise
speaker I would like to make a motion
State your motion
[Music]
without objection
sold
committee on finance to which Jose
referred Senate Bill 172 FN an act
allowing court appointed Guardians to
receive temporary assistance who needed
family benefits consider the same report
the same with the recommendation of Bill
ought to pass Jess Edwards for the
committee
bill was on second reading Open Door
further Amendment
representative Lynn office floor
Amendment 2116 h
and as representative Lynn is recognized
to speak
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues I rise in support of this
amendment
this amendment adds to SB 172 the
verbatim text of House Bill 117 as
passed by this body on March 9th of this
year with a strong bipartisan vote the
vote in fact on a roll call was 207 211
to 157.
please recall that the purpose of of
House Bill 117 was to overrule a 2005
Supreme Court decision that essentially
makes the term of a lease that is the
length of a lease unenforceable if you
are a landlord so that for example a
one-year lease means it's a one-year
lease for the tenant but not for the
landlord if at the end of the term the
landlord wishes to terminate the lease
that does not provide a basis to evict
the tenant because according to that
Supreme Court decision the end of the
contract is not good cause for an
eviction
bear in mind that the rule as
established by that Supreme Court
decision applies not just to Big
landlords but to small landlords who
rent out as few as two rental units if
they are not single-family homes and if
they are not owner occupied
the court decision was criticized by
Justice Joseph Neto an appointee of
Governor Shaheen in a special
concurrence he wrote that the effect of
the Supreme Court's ruling was to render
least terms annullity and to Grant
tenants a Perpetual lease where that was
where there was no evidence that that
was what the legislature intended
HB 117 and this amendment corrects the
Court's error by saying that the end of
a tenancy is a proper basis to evict a
tenant but the tenant but the landlord
must give 30 days notice and there is an
exception for very short-term leases
although this house overwhelmed or
although this house by a substantial
vote passed this bill it was itl in the
Senate
um it was itl on a Voice vote and
although we don't have a record people
who were in The Gallery and supported
the bill indicate that it appeared
they're not they're not contesting that
that it was in fact itl but they do
indicate that it was a close vote
um
passage of this amendment
will help to make
housing available to marginalized people
as I said at the time the bill was
before the Senate before this body
before a landlord is more likely to take
a risk on a person who might be a might
be sort of a marginalized or a
questionable tenant maybe with a spotty
credit record or whatever if the
landlord knows that if the landlord
proposes a one-year lease it really
means it's one year not that the
landlord is on the hook forever if the
landlord under as under current law
knows that I may be on the hook forever
then it's much less likely that the
landlord would be open to considering a
marginalized tenant hmm
we we in this body agreed with that
analysis but the Senate did not
by attaching this amendment to sb150 SB
172 a non-controversial bill that both
Chambers support
the other chamber will have to
reevaluate its position
and likely we'll see the wisdom of The
house's efforts to enhance housing
availability
so if you voted for this bill before
I respectfully ask that you do so again
now by supporting this amendment
and if you didn't vote for House Bill
117 before I respectfully request that
you rethink your position and hopefully
change your view
the current state of New Hampshire law
on this issue I submit respectfully
really is an embarrassment and cries out
to be fixed thank you Mr Speaker and I
ask for a division vote
chair recognizes cam Kenny
thank you Mr Speaker
so I urge my colleagues to vote against
this floor Amendment this amendment
would essentially make it easier to
evict a tenant without any legitimate
reasoning
um so let's start by just briefly going
over the good cause statute currently
landlords who lease restricted property
must have good cause for eviction this
is a fair and balanced law that has been
in effect since 1985.
good cause offers landlords a number of
reasons including business and economic
reasons to justify a conviction
this includes when attendant doesn't
increase to a rent increase wanting to
renovate or take the unit off the market
or wanting to run it to a family member
also without this amendment landlords
can already evict for non-payment of
rent
uh damaging the property or really any
violation of the lease so in short this
amendment will not in any way help
marginalized people this amendment would
significantly weaken the good cause
eviction statute when there are a number
of legitimate reasons that a landlord
can evict a tenant without this
amendment as the Supreme Court held in
2005 arbitrarily evicting someone at the
end of a lease term is not good cause
ending this law that has offered
protection from arbitrary loss of
housing for 40 years during a time when
there is a housing crisis will expose
thousands of granite Staters to Great
harm
therefore I respectfully ask my
colleagues to press the red button and
kill this amendment thank you Mr Speaker
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment 2116h a division has been
requested members will take their seats
all right
the motion before us is the Lin house
will be in order
is the Lynn floor Amendment 2116 this is
a division vote share recognized
representative Lynn for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this amendment restores the
fundamental principle of law that
contact contracts are supposed to mean
what they say and if I also know that
passing this amendment
will help to improve the availability of
rental housing to marginalized
individuals by giving landlords reason
to take a chance on renting to such
persons and finally if I know that
adding this amendment to SB 172 a
non-controversial bill that will pass
this chamber whether or not uh this
amendment is adopted but passing this
amendment will likely cause the other
chamber behind the wall to rethink its
erroneous position on this issue than
would I support the passage of this
amendment by passing by pushing the
green button thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognizes representative magliari for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker as
someone who voted incorrectly when this
bill came up the first time and has
learned the error of his ways and Mr
Speaker if I know that current New
Hampshire law provides that landlords do
not have to put up with and can evict
tenants who don't pay their rent destroy
property who have pets when they are not
supposed to or who are disruptive to
other tenants and Mr Speaker if I know
that the New Hampshire law gives the
landlord the right to require a rental
application from the prospective tenants
allows landlords to charge an
application fee for the time and effort
they take to review the application and
calls tenants pass landlords or personal
recommendations now without this
amendment
and if I know that landlords that live
in buildings where they rent or
landlords that rent commercials seasonal
recreational or single-family homes can
initiate the eviction process or
cancellation of a lease at any time
without good cause without this
amendment then Mr Speaker would I now
push the red button so that another
motion can be made thank you
the motion before us is the Lynn Flora
Amendment 2116h this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
185 voting 888 voting a before Amendment
fails senator of Edwards did not vote
clearing the conflict
we're back now to Auto pass as amended
ought to pass
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
opposing a
[Applause]
[Music]
the eyes have it committee report is
adopted
we have
some announcements
the chair recognizes representative
Alexander
thank you Mr Speaker everyone should
have received saved the day from New
Hampshire Realtors if you did not notice
the big tent outside there's free lunch
for All-State reps so join me on the
lawn thank you
I recognize representative D Simone for
an announcement
thank you Mr Speaker to all of my
colleagues there will be a meeting of
the owls
thank you in the Webster room bring your
lunch
and and enjoy the Lively conversation
that we'll have thank you
chair recognize representative Wilhelm
from announcement
thank you Mr Speaker Democrats will
caucus representative the house will be
in order
Democrats will caucus downstairs in the
cafeteria at one o'clock sharp don't be
late thanks
Geo recognize representative Osborne
Republicans we will caucus right now in
the hall and uh go get lunch afterwards
the house the house will be in recessed
for until
1 30.
foreign
foreign Mr Speaker the Senate concurs
with the House of Representatives and
the passage of the following entitled
bill with amendment in the passage of
which amendment the Senate has the
concurrence of the house has Bill 1A
making Appropriations for the expenses
of certain Departments of the state for
fiscal years ending June 30 2024 and
June 30 2025.
representative Weiler moves we Concur
and the chair recognize representative
Sweeney
thank you Mr Speaker
House Bill one is the product of
bipartisan and bicameral negotiations
that have taken place over the course of
this entire legislative session
this budget package is balanced Cuts
taxes and our expanding economy further
increases State revenues without
increasing a single tax or fee House
Bill one is the numbers document and we
can build on the historic president that
The Voice vote in April set for us by
concurring with the other body on House
Bill 1 today thank you
[Music]
we'll call
representative Senator Harrington
requests a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it's not sufficiently seconded
the motion before us
is
House Bill one to concur on House Bill
one are you ready for the question
the division has been requested
members take your seats
Rewards
yogurt is here too
clear
the motion before us is concurrence on
House Bill one this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you opposed or press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
representatives shewitt and
representative groda
hello
members president of the opportunity
vote also attend the state of the vote
351 voting a 25 voting May
House Bill one is accepted
recognize the clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house and the patches of the following
entitled bill with amendments in the
passage of which amendments the Senate
has to concurrence of the house House
Bill 2 FNA local relative to State fees
funds revenues and expenditures
what does that representative Wilder
moves we concur chair recognizes
representative Pearson
Stephen Pearson
thank you Mr Speaker
thank you honorable colleagues
if you'd asked me a month ago if I would
ever have had to speak on House Bill 2 I
would have said no I don't want to be
here
but I have to be here
I have to be here for two reasons one
for the record Representative Steve
Pearson Rockingham District 13 Derry
member of the pension system
remember of a lot of things
really
the first reason I rise in opposition to
this is because I have to in the effect
of
the educational formula my school
district is the third largest school
district in the state of New Hampshire
the numbers that are there I I can't
even fathom why Dairy was
grossly neglected
in that calculation
the second reason I Rise
in opposition to House Bill 2 is in
reference to a substantial effort made
by this body
this year to right or wrong
and I want to just address some grossly
inaccurate statements that have been
made lately
I think this is important to set the
record straight
the pension restoration part
that we voted on 282 to 80.
which is way past the veto proof
has been referred to as a sweetener bill
by the executive branch
that's far from reality
it restored some of the items just some
that were retroactively taken away from
our First Responders it provided no new
benefit of any kind
returning something that was stolen from
you is never sweetening anything
then we had to deal with a lobbying
group that created a false fiscal
analysis
pension related items are processed by
the retirement system that is their
function
and the costs associated with
legislation are processed by a
consulting firm an Actuarial firm that
the state has used for 20 years
this lobbying group
decided to create their own
they included irrelevant items
in their analysis
they included items that occurred in
past legislative sessions I've never
seen I've been here three terms I've
never seen that tactic before
and even they included items that were
already bought and paid for
and then they claimed it was the true
analysis and at one point there were
folks getting this analysis attached to
the one from the retirement system it
kind of made it look like it went
together
this lobbying group doesn't have an
actuary on their staff
they're not qualified to do this
analysis
and yet that's what they presented to
the Senate
thirdly there have been repeated
inaccurate statements
that this bill reintroduces spiking
back into the pension system
spiking is when an employee has the
ability to manipulate their work
schedules and conditions
to overly inflate their pension
something I abhor
in all of the folks in this room that
deal with the pension system have no
tolerance for
of the anti-spiking provisions that were
enacted from 2007 to 2011 remain in law
in fact the anti-spiking provisions were
expanded
they were expanded
by extending the pension cap back from
2009 to 2001. a hard pension cap is the
ultimate
anti-spiking provision
the stakeholders agreed for the first
time in a decade
they agreed with each other that was a
Monumental task in and of itself but
they agreed to dozens of concessions
finance division one unanimously voted
on this
when this bill
House Bill 436 came before this body
the fiscal note on it was 258 million
dollars to be paid over 10 years
through substantial work we got that
cost down to a hundred
we voted
in a veto proof majority at 258 million
we found that acceptable in this body
since then we've dropped it to a hundred
with a reduction in pension debt on top
of funding this
thanks to the efforts of Representative
Joe Sweeney we found dedicated funding
source for this
to pay for this without having to use
any general fund appropriation
we made this fix easy
this body in the in 2011
did something that no other state had
done
it retroactively modified our pension
system
for our First Responders despite article
23 of our state constitution
every single state dealt with pension
problems between 07 and 2012 in the
District of Columbia
nobody else
retroactively hurt their people just us
that should tell you something
this leaves New Hampshire alone
still in this
we continue to stick our heads in the
sand and ignore the massive problem we
have
in emergency services with hiring and
retaining people
we just saw for those of you out
West
Keen
the closing
of a much needed ambulance service out
there
prior to 2011 New Hampshire was
competitive in the New England Regional
labor market
today we're dead last
why did this happen
what was the real reason
it is claimed it was to make up a 900
million dollar budget shortfall
okay
if that's true then in an era of three
budget Cycles
with substantial surpluses
why could we not restore that which was
cut
or maybe that wasn't the reason at all
thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise to make a motion
I'd like to move to table this bill
it is a proper motion and I'd like to
speak to my motion
it's not debatable I thought you could
speak
it is a proper motion the motion before
us is the table House Bill too
if I not
yes
not yet
are you ready for the question
the vision has been requested
division
the motion before us is the table House
Bill too this a division vote chair
recognizer representative Harrington for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill has 208 separate
parts and that practically nobody has
read them all and almost nobody
understands them Mr Speaker if I know
this is supposed to be conquered not
Washington will we actually read bills
before we vote for them but I now push
the green button to table this bill so
it will be brought back at a later time
after people actually understand what
they're voting on
chair recognize Representative Steven
Smith for a parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker
if I know a lot of the people that have
a lot of blood Blood Sweat and Tears
into this budget and that at this time
we should hear any debate that comes up
and deal with it now because deal with
it at a later time there is no later
time this is a motion on whether to
concur or not than what I press the red
button
the motion before us is the table House
Bill too this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you opposed to press the red
button loading stations are open for 30
seconds
thank you
representative partial representative
woodcock
representative partial
thank you
representative Perez
and
Paul Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
say to the vote
44 voting Aid 334 voting a the motion
fails the chair recognizes
representative Dan Maguire
thank you Mr Speaker I have a different
perspective on the pension aspects
that are not currently in-house Bill too
but were in-house Bill too when it left
this body
months ago
um
first of all let's start with a little
bit of History a year ago
um we passed a bill that improved the
pensions of the group in question the
group of group two firefighters hired
from one date to another but roughly a
10 or so year period
and the cost of that bill was a little
over 40 million dollars
the bill is originally this was House
Bill
1578 I think from a year ago and and the
bill was originally maybe 56 million
dollars it came to the house finance
committee it was reduced to 40 42
million dollars it went over to the
other side passed unanimously signed
into law by the governor so already in
the current biennium the biennium we're
in right now we have improved pensions
for this exact same group of people by
40 something million dollars
this year a bill was proposed House Bill
which was a significant additional
Improvement
and and restoration that that's correct
um for that same group
and
um it would have been you know the
original fiscal note was roughly 250
million dollars spread out over 10 years
25 million dollars a year for 10 years
now I would disagree with my friend from
Derry on the on the aspect of spiking
because this that bill House Bill 436
changed the definitions of income and
the definitions of average final
compensation
as well as some other features the the
multiplier and the age at which
retirement could be someone could retire
and so on
but this in specific the definitions of
what is income that is where spiking
occurs so for example if someone is
allowed to take sick days as a large
lump sum at the end just before
retirement
then that and have that count as though
they had a large salary that last year
that significantly affects retirement
and the the definitions that is
currently in place for that group and in
fact it's in place for every employee
not just group two but it's in place for
group ones as well
does not allow that kind of spiking all
right this bill House Bill 436 changed
those definitions back to the previous
set of definitions that were in place
when this particular group was hired but
not yet vested
and so
um
during when the bill came to our
committee to the finance division one
I suggested
why don't we take out those definition
changes
and and and consider just the other
changes the the multiplier the age and
so on all right separately okay because
the definition changes is something that
applies to everyone group one you know
we're talking about teachers state
employees everybody all right it was not
something done special for group two all
right the other parts were but this part
was not
and I'm told by the retirement system
that doing that alone just leaving the
definitions the way they are
changes the 250 million to something
more like 75 million
okay so so this to what I think of as
the spiking aspects are a significant
part of this bill
okay now let's talk about what happened
to the bill once it left us all right
I've had extensive discussions with the
chair of the other finance committee
he's someone I know quite well because
we sat next to each other in division
four for two years
and the the problem is as we sent it the
250 million dollars
it was simply sticker shock right they
passed the 40 million dollars a year
earlier no problem at all 24 to nothing
you know everybody liked it right but
but jumping on you know trying to ask it
was too big of an ask
and the problem and so you might say
well why didn't they cut it down to
something and then we could have
Committee of conference and we could we
could negotiate the the problem is you
in order to negotiate maybe if you're
trying to sell your car for 25
000 and the buyer wants to pay 20 000.
you can negotiate all right
but when one side wants 250 million and
the other side might be willing to do 50
million or something there's no
negotiation position right you you
you're too far apart all right and so
what they what they did in the budget
that we're voting on right now
is they took this out and unfortunately
I'm very disappointed they also took out
house bill 50 which was the pay down of
the pension system uh pension unfunded
liability that we all voted for or many
of us did and um that kind of got lost
in the in the shuffle
and um and they put in a commission a
very you know high level sort of
commission to think about
improving the pension system for
everyone
not just this particular group of group
two employees you know hired from one
year to to another but all group two
employees because this particular group
already has a pension better than the
ones that are younger than them
so they already have a pension that's
that's superior to the ones that we're
hiring today
and so if our concern is hiring and
retention maybe we ought to think about
the younger ones as well
right and that's what this commission is
for
so I think they're serious about doing
something
but but they it was too big of an ask
you know the we asked for the stars and
they might have been willing to give us
a piece of the moon or something like
that you know so it was too big of an
ask and this is their way of saying to
us sorry we need more time we we need a
different structure you know it's not
going to work this way and not only by
the way did they take out the pension
staff
but they took the state's wallet
and locked it away they left all of our
spare change in the education trust fund
so where it can't be used
for this kind of thing so so they really
are sending us a serious message that
they don't want
what we tried to do okay but I I think
it is not over right and one thing I've
learned being here a few terms nothing
is ever over right we're always talking
we're always working and so not only do
we have the commission but we still own
house bill 436.
so we have retained it it'll come out
and so on and I don't think you know
it's not like the other body is somehow
opposed to group two employees
right I mean that's that's just silly
but we asked for too much that's that's
the bottom line Thank you Mr Speaker
I recognize representative Prout
thank you Mr Speaker
this bill includes several sections that
together drastically expand the mission
and potentially number of police
officers in New Hampshire
we've already debated these sections
back in April and this house voted
overwhelmingly to remove them
this would be enough for me to ask you
to press the red button on this motion
and
the motion to accept the changes made by
the other the body on the other side of
the wall
however there's also the fact that this
bill was passed in the other body less
than 24 hours ago with several
substantive floor amendments
I haven't had the chance to fully study
it have you
we've all heard the quote you need to
pass the bill to find out what's in it
that's not the New Hampshire way we're
not up against a house deadline for this
motion it's being rushed unnecessarily
please press the red button to say no to
this dangerous Fast Track so another
motion can be made to send this bill to
a committee conference in other words
the normal process for a budget bill
thank you Mr Speaker
do you recognize representative Waller
I rise today to urge the members of the
house to vote to concur with House Bill
2 as amended by the Senate
the house sent the Senate a budget that
house Democrats and Republicans came
together on
remember that historic vote when we
passed the house Budget on a Voice vote
by working together we were able to
provide a desperately needed rate
increase for our Medicaid providers
and the Senate recognized the importance
of our work and included the house level
of funding in their budget
the important pay raise for our valuable
state employees remains unchanged from
the house budget
in areas of housing
the Senate added an additional five
million dollars to the house budget and
by a rearranging the Appropriations they
applied 10 million dollars for homeless
support for our cities and towns
education funding formula is similar to
the house formula spending slightly more
than the house but both planned to
increase school funding to our
communities over the current level of
funding
Senate budget includes 20 million
additional dollars for municipal Bridges
and apportionment funds that our
communities need
to keep our bridges safe
and two million dollars was added to
bolster our Vital pfast remediation
program
the Senate
work
that the house had done by adding needed
funding in several areas child care
Family Resource Centers ctes and mental
health
just to name a few the Senate was able
to use
2023 surplus funds to provide much of
the additional funding for these vital
services
but still they were able to deposit
close to 63 million in the rainy day
fund at the end of the biennium
like all budgets
we do not get everything we want
but this budget goes a long way to
meeting the needs of New Hampshire
citizens and communities
we can all name something we wish was
not in this budget
and we can all name something that we
wish was in this budget but it did not
make it
coming to a compromise is what happens
when we listen to each other and come to
agreement
it does not mean we give up on our
budget concerns no it means we keep
working on the areas where we could not
reach agreement
and over the next several months
we will continue to work on some areas
where agreement was not reached
this session we have learned an
important lesson about working together
the legislation we pass is much stronger
when we work together Democrats and
Republicans
House and Senate
this budget is an example of policy
makers putting forth their best efforts
I urge you to support the concur motion
on the house Budget on House Bill 2 as
amended by the Senate
do you recognize representative Sanborn
I rise in support of concurring on House
Bill 2.
building a state budget isn't easy
especially when you have to craft it to
meet the diverse needs of the people of
New Hampshire and pass muster with the
majority of 424 members of the House and
Senate
no state budget budget that I've ever
seen is perfect but we can never let
perfect be the enemy of good
personally I would have liked to see
some of the pension reform efforts that
the house passed for our police and fire
but I fully recognize that compromise is
how we get things done and I look
forward to continuing the conversation
on pension reform moving forward
so let me highlight some of the good
things in this budget that we can all be
proud of over 200 million dollars in
Millis and rooms tax distributions to
municipalities over 70 million dollars
in Highway block grants to
municipalities
six million dollars for municipal Bridge
Aid grants
160 million increase from Medicaid
provider rates
investments in affordable housing and
homelessness services
investments in mental health system of
care for the elderly and child care
competitive pay increases within state
government to help us compete in this
tough labor market and continue to
provide services for our citizens
emergency power reforms
accelerated phase out of the interest
and dividends tax
reauthorization of Medicaid expansion
with a seven year Sunset to give the
legislature authority to reevaluate it
and most importantly record investment
in education over two billion dollars
over the biennium where no municipality
gets less money and Aid is targeted to
the towns with the greatest need
we can nitpick this for hours but let's
face it the Senate based their budget
based on the hard work of the house
budget and the majority of what is in
the Senate is what we can all be
supportive of something that both
parties can promote as a win for the
State of New Hampshire
this is not the end of the process and
we will continue through this year and
next year to find solutions to our
state's problems big and small
but join me now in this historic vote to
concur with our colleagues and move
forward with a budget New Hampshire
needs now thank you
the motion before us is occur on House
Bill 2. I
representative Hines requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded members take
your seats
the motion before us just occur on House
Bill 2.
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizer representative
Harrington for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that there actually are cuts to
education Aid to many many towns in this
bill because inflation is running way
over 10 percent over the two-year period
and most towns are getting way less than
that if I also know that again there's
208 different changes in this bill to
the state budget the implementation of
and I know that nobody has read all of
them and certainly nobody understands
them all so I urge people to wait until
you've actually read the bill it may be
a great bill but we don't know that now
so please push the red button
share recognize Representative Steven
Smith for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that in my seven terms I have
never not once voted for a budget I was
completely happy with because I don't
get everything I want
but Mr Speaker if I'm going to do today
what I did then and vote for the budget
that reflects the opinions of a few
hundred people because it's our job then
when I press the green button
motion before us is to concur on House
Bill two this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you opposed or press the red
button the voting stations are open for
30 seconds
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote
I also attend the state of the vote
326 voting a 53 voting a
House Bill 2 is adopted
I believe
we kind of just made history
when we passed a budget on a Voice vote
and we just passed the buy-in a
bipartisan budget
with probably the highest numbers we've
ever seen
this chamber deserves some
congratulations
thank you
for what reason is a memorize do you
make a motion stage of motion I move
that the remarks of the speaker be
placed into the permanent Journal
kind of kind of strange for me to say
without objection but I guess I will
without objection
committee on finance to which was
referred Senate bill to all four FN
enact requiring trauma kids to be
available in state-owned buildings and
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment instead of Dan McGuire for the
committee the amendment is
2080h printed in house record 27 pages
48-49
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it an
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye those opposed nay the
eyes have it and the committee report is
adopted
thank you
the committee on labor industrial and
rehabilitative services to which was for
its Senate Bill 42 FN relative to
overpayment of unemployment compensation
comes without recommendation
representative
seaworth
office Amendment
representative SeaWorld moves ought to
pass and offers Amendment
1799 Clinton and house record 27 page 25
and is
authorized to speak
thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise to ask your support on this
amendment
this amendment
accomplishes
all the goals of the original bill but
does it without some of the unintended
consequences
so the question is what are those goals
of the original Bill and that does get a
little complicated
has explained to the committee the
purpose of submitting SB 42 was to
address a situation that came up during
the covet pandemic
as I think we all know the unemployment
system came under some strain then with
more people applying for unemployment
benefits more people receiving them the
rules changing on who is eligible for
for benefits and federal money coming in
to make up some of that difference in
funding
um
it got very complicated and it was
confusing
now just one of these complications
involves what happens in the case that
Departments of Labor call overpayment
more specifically what happens when
someone applies for unemployment
but misrepresents their situation and
then receives money for which they are
not eligible
the simple answer is they have to pay it
back
but there's a difference between state
and federal law under state law
any money that's not paid back to the
trust fund within a timely fashion will
accumulate interest
in federal law that doesn't occur and so
this bill is amended will address that
situation and it will do it through the
Department's rulemaking process
now that probably sounds even more
complicated but I think it's a lot
simpler than it sounds because the
existing department rules already deal
with this what happens
when there are differing individual
situations
and and when you play pay interest
um
you'll probably hear from some of the
other speakers about some of those
conditions where people really shouldn't
be
paying interest when they're already
down when they're already out of work
but there's a lot of gray area between
you got money that was no fault of your
own and you got money by committing a
felony and you're going to jail
and through the rulemaking process we
can address that continuum
just to give an example
under the current rules whether you pay
interest or not is not a given an
obvious exception is let's say I receive
money for which I was not eligible but
it was through no fault of my own in
that case I get to keep the money and
obviously I don't pay any interest on it
but what if it was my fault
if I if that money that I wasn't
supposed to receive that isn't mine if I
can give that back to the state within
the time limit then I also don't pay
interest
if I can't
and I go to the state and I work out a
payment plan
then that interest will be waived at the
end of it when I've paid off the
original amount
and if my financial situation is such
that I simply can't afford to pay the
money back the rules in place already
allow for giving that debt
so this amendment despite its length
really is simple extending that process
to the interest so that it won't be
charged up front rather than being
waived at the at the end now it is true
that there are other states many states
that don't charge interest at all
but if you look at it many of those
states have other ways to chase down to
claw back this money that is owed by
people who shouldn't have gotten in the
first place in New Hampshire this is it
if someone doesn't pay back money that
they shouldn't have received our only
way to motivate them to pay it back is
that if they don't pay it in a timely
fashion then interest begins to accrue
we have the underlying Bill the amended
Bill we're both going for the same goal
I'm just asking you to support me I
believe as amended that
um this is a better path to getting to
where we want to be
so I ask you please support the Motion
Plus press the green button thank you Mr
Speaker
chair recognizes representative Brian
Sullivan
thank you Mr thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in opposition to amendment number
1799h
in the words of the sponsor of sb42 this
amendment effectively guts the bill
the intent of the bill is we received it
from the other body is to prevent the
Department of Employment Security from
charging interest on overpayments of
benefits it except in instances and this
is a quote where the recipient willfully
makes a false statement or
representation or knowingly fails to
disclose a material fact to obtain or
increase unemployment compensation
the process of obtaining an unemployment
compensation involves filing with the
Department on a weekly basis to provide
assurance that the recipient is doing
everything necessary to remain qualified
and by providing earnings information to
establish the amount of compensation
that is due
it is not difficult to make a mistake in
one or more of these weekly applications
I suggest that no interest should be
charged on the overpayment when the
overpayment is due to an honest mistake
it should indeed be repaid but without
the accrual of Interest
this amendment allows the department to
decide on a case-by-case basis whether
to charge interest or not
the department has assured us they will
write rules to determine when it would
exercise this this discretion that this
amendment provides
I suggest rather than writing rules on
its discretion the department might
instead write rules to Define when a
fraudulent claim has occurred
this would honor the intent of the bill
and treat the unemployment recipients
fairly
please join me in pressing the red
button to defeat defeat this amendment
and Mr Speaker I ask for a division vote
oh
I'm sorry I didn't hear you Mr Speaker
was I recognized
yes thank you all right guys I
understand all right labor after launch
not probably the cool thing I was
watching people I know we're all falling
to see from our wonderful lunch we had
from the Real Estate Association so I'm
going to be brief and provide some facts
here
State of New Hampshire
if you get unemployment benefits and for
some reason you don't shouldn't have
received them you have to pay it back
with interest 15 states in this country
do that
another 20 do not but the the balance of
them
they take it from you some other way
if there's an income tax in your state
they will take your income tax return
okay they can Levy your wages we don't
do any of that in New Hampshire
okay it's simple
if you are have committed fraud the
Fraud Unit comes after you
but there's a lot of these gray areas in
between and this is the New Hampshire
way of not going after anybody for
making mistakes but kind of on the
bubble of were they mistakes or we just
did not quite tell them the truth
these are examples
someone gets laid off excuse me someone
quits
then goes to unemployment Securities
this is a true story it says
um
I I uh I got excuse me they quit someone
comes advice I got laid off so they get
benefits and what happens is the
department sends something to the
employer the employer writes back no
they quit
that individual had to pay that money
back
another situation where someone a
seasonal employee received a bonus when
they left at the end of the season
well according to unemployment
Securities you need to report that they
didn't
they received that bonus the same time
they were receiving unemployment
benefits that's wrong that's fraudulent
but the department doesn't want to go
after everybody for some of these small
infractions
sometimes the department is wrong
at a situation where a woman went for a
job went and got some training she was
paid while she was training that day
she did not report the income she didn't
end up taking the job didn't like the
job did not report the income but then
two weeks later dawned on her when she
filled out the form I have to say that I
received this income
she went for a hearing the hearings
officer said
okay we would think that's a mistake
We're Not Gonna
ask you to pay that back
it is very common in the state of New
Hampshire
to allow departments to have
uh decision-making Authority on these
things it's well known in the Department
of Labor if you do not have workers
compensation it's a twenty five hundred
dollar fine plus a hundred dollars a day
per person per day
the department doesn't always go after
people for fifty thousand dollars goes
in at workers compensation for six
months if they deemed it was a mistake
so they'll come up with a fine they'll
agree on something for about twenty five
hundred dollars that's the New Hampshire
way of doing things that's a May versus
a shell we talked about that someone
brought that up earlier today a May
versus a shell in our laws that's what
this amendment tries to do make it a May
versus a show
give the discretion through rulemaking
to allow the department to go after the
people that are really fraudulent
and the people that kind of make a
mistake and don't quite
tell the whole story or whatever we
don't want to cause a problem
where we're going after people that's
not what New Hampshire does
all the benefits are paid 100 by the
employer into the work unemployment fund
we should not allow people to
be able to get funds they don't deserve
because it will hurt the people that do
deserve those unemployment benefits
the amendment allows a department to go
to rules
and to be able to make these decisions
so they can be fair with people
this one either this thing about we pay
interest we charge you interest nope now
we're not going to charge you any
interest
why why are we going from here to there
was a some discussion that we don't
trust the department you know I don't I
don't know what to tell you I serve on
the unemployment the unemployment
Securities Advisory Board we look at
these guys every quarter we have a
meeting we check and see what they they
do and let me tell you something
during covert those people worked really
hard they work 12 hours a day to make
sure people got their unemployment
benefits I have no qualms whatsoever
with the decisions the unemployment
Securities is made and I've never heard
anyone complain about it I would ask you
to go with the amendment it's the New
Hampshire way it's the Fairway and it
cuts this down the middle thank you Mr
Speaker
Senator Sullivan has asked for a
division vote members take your seats
thank you
members take your seats
the motion before us is amendment
1799 this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative Leclerc
for a parliamentary inquiry
my name is Dan Leclair and I'm one of
four representatives from Amherst it's
my first time up here
Mr Speaker if I know that it is not
difficult to make a mistake when filing
for weekly unemployment benefits
and if I know that there is no malicious
intent to collect more than what was
owed in weekly benefits
and if I also know that the recipient is
willing to pay the full amount of the
employment back to the Department of
Employment Security
then Mr Speaker what I push the red
button so as Not to cause an even higher
burden on a person that has been
collecting unemployment benefits and
avoid the interest fees thank you
Joe recognize president of infantine for
a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the amendment
makes
a decent Bill a lot better
and will be good for employers and
employees
where I vote for the amendment vote
green please
motion before us is the amendment 1799
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your upholster press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
represent Reynolds
ball member president had an opportunity
to vote
also attend the state of the vote
186 yays 187 Nays the amendment fails
the motion before us now is an ought to
pass
the chair recognizes representative
infantine
missed it by that much
one of my concerns
having done this for a number of years
is seeing how other states do things
the departments in New Hampshire
are so much different than some of the
states to our state to our East and our
South
as to how they deal with people
and I'm concerned that by passing this
bill
we will put Employment Securities in a
position where
they won't give these people a pass
anymore
one of these examples I gave it was
eight hundred dollars it was had to be
returned the other one was 300 and the
other one was 133 dollars
will they consider these just fraud and
go after more
I think it's a good possibility and I
think that was a darn shame
I I always question why we mess with
something that's
not broken
I would ask you to vote no on the bill
all right please
chair recognize representative Sullivan
needed by this much
I want to set the record straight this
is not about trust for the Department of
Employment Security
I have
I would expect an equal amount of
respect for those folks as my chairman
does
this is just about defining exactly
where the line is
for where you charge interest or don't
and you know I think the the bills that
came from
the other side of the wall
made it pretty clear if you engaged in
misrep intentional misrepresent
misrepresentation
then you're going to pay interest
if it reaches the level of fraud you're
probably going to go to jail
um
but the bottom line is if it was an
honest mistake
and errors are commonly made then there
will be no interest you'll pay back the
amount that you weren't entitled to but
you won't pay any interest so I think
it's it's a fair line to draw if you if
it's a mistake no interest if it's
intentional you pay interest so I ask
you to support the bill as it came to
this body thank you
motion before us is ought to pass in
Senate Bill authority too
are you ready for the question
your vision has been called members take
your seats
representative Sweeney requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 42 this is a division vote
share recognizes representative of
Italian for parliamentary inquiry
there's an eventine waves off chair
recognize representative
some solo waves off okay
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button it's
a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
thank you
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the vote
196 voting a
178.98 committee report is adopted
got it
[Music]
the majority of the committee on labor
industrial and rehabilitative services
to which was referred Senate Bill 193 an
act relative to the obligation of
collective bargaining units to negotiate
in good faith having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation at the
bill ochsu passed with Amendment
representative Brian seaworth for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
in expedient to legislate representative
Lino avalani for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is
1800h printed in house record 27 on page
48. questions on the amendment be ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
all those opposed nay
all right then the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted
the question now is on the report of
Archer pass with Amendment
representative abalani is recognized to
speak against the report
thank you Mr Speaker
we've heard bills a few bills this year
that try to legislate items that should
be part of the contract negotiation
process in my experience as a member of
this committee we have tried to make
sure the negotiations between labor and
management have not been subject to
intrusions by state law
while there are items in law that set
dates for specific budgetary deadlines
this bill tries to define a bargaining
process by creating an arbitrary number
of days to begin the negotiation process
it is a minority position that this is
an item that should be negotiated for
and not placed in state law thank you Mr
Speaker
representative Sullivan's recognized to
speak and support the report
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in support of sb193
scp-193 is a simple bill that will help
keep public sector negotiations
operating efficiently
it requires public sector employees
employers and employee groups to meet
for negotiations within 10 business days
after one party or the other has
provided a written request
this timeline can be waived through
mutual agreement
it is unusual for an employer or an
employee group to delay meeting with the
other party
when it does happen though it's a sign
of significant dysfunction
it has been argued that the legislature
should not interfere with the parties
during negotiations I would generally
agree that issues should be worked out
between the parties
in this case the parties are showing
that they are unable or unwilling to
work things out
by passing SB 193 we will provide the
the gentle nudge needed to keep
negotiations moving along
we are not telling them what to
negotiate or what to agree on we're
simply telling them to engage in the
process
RSA 273a already requires the parties to
meet this bill simply puts a definition
on how soon they must meet
the Public Employee Labor Relations
Board would enforce this rule but it
would not likely be needed as a 10
business day requirement would be easy
to comply with
please push the green button to support
this bipartisan piece of legislation and
Mr Speaker I request a division vote
questions on the majority report of
outside pass as amended are you ready
for the question
well does somebody say division
this will be a division vote members
take your seats
thank you
the questions on the report of acha pass
as amended
this is a division vote representative
infant science recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know the labor
committee does not like to get involved
with dictating rules and procedures for
negotiations and Municipal contracts
if I know that this better left up to
the nlrb to decide
and that creating an arbitrary amount of
days is 10 days to Define what is bad
faith
is doing exactly what the committee does
not like to do I would ask you to vote
no
representative Bouchard's recognized for
parliamentary incorrect
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I believe
it is the obligation of the public
employer and the certified employee
organization to negotiate in good faith
and Mr Speaker if I believe good faith
involves meeting at a reasonable time
and place
and Mr Speaker
if I believe that good faith means to
meet within 10 business days after
receipt of a written request from the
other party
to meet
to bargain then Mr Speaker would I press
the green button in support of art to
pass SB 193 thank you Mr Speaker
the questions on the committee report of
ultra pass as amended this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
okay
damn smart
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
200 in the affirmative 171 and the
negative the report is adopted
thank you
the committee on Municipal and County
governments which was reserved referred
Senate Bill 110 FN local relative to
residency status comes to us without
recommendation
representative majority moves ought to
pass
representative Richard Brown is
recognized to speak against the motion
thank you Mr speaker thank you fellow
Representatives the analysis of this
bill states that its intent is to
clarify residency of transient
individuals for the purpose of
determining determining responsibility
for local assistance instead of
clarifying however the bill makes the
process more difficult and unclear
current irsa states that any person
unable to support themselves is entitled
to temporary assistance
irsa also already specifies that costs
are to be paid for by the town of
residence of the person
this bill restricts a person's rights by
placing a 30-day restriction on an
individual requiring them to support
themselves without municipal or other
provider assistance in order to
transition residency to a new
municipality
and would restrict someone's ability to
choose their place of residence based on
a homeless or transient condition
how can a homeless person support
themselves and possibly their family
without assistance the bill appears to
be more about changes in residency than
about renumeration for services rendered
this bill is completely unnecessary and
Ashley makes things more difficult for
those who find themselves homeless
please vote against this motion of ought
to pass by pressing the red button so
another motion can be made and brought
to the floor thank you
representative priest is recognized to
speak in support of the motion
thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise to speak for the motion to ought
to pass Senate Bill 110 relative to
residency status
this bill clarifies the residence
residency status of transient
individuals to determine responsibility
for local assistance
New Hampshire has experienced an
increase of homeless people and Families
according to the New Hampshire coalition
to end homelessness the number of
unsheltered homeless people have doubled
since 2000.
and this has affected all communities
in New Hampshire
SB 110 is a bipartisan initiative that
will establish a common ground fair and
Equitable agreement on residency
concerning people receiving services
from hospitals Correctional Facilities
treatment program centers emergency
temporary housing services and
placements outside of a municipal
Municipality of origin
clarification of residency for local
welfare purposes only will increase
Municipal liability fairness while
continuing to comply with the
humanitarian obligations as indicated in
our current RSA
by clarifying The Residency status for
transient individuals
this bill opens up the communication and
collaboration of assistance between the
resident community and the community
providing services
believe In fairness
and Equitable agreement between
municipalities
I urge all of you to pass the green
button and support the ought to pass
sb110
[Music]
and I asked for a division vote thank
you
the question is on the motion of ought
to pass on Senate Bill 170 all
representative Glen Circa requests a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
yep this will be a roll call vote
members please take your seats
the question is on the motion about to
pass on Senate Bill 110
and this is a roll call vote
representative Glen circus recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
and be nice if we could hear him
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this bill comes to the house
floor without recommendation and came
out of our committee in a non-partisan
vote
and if I know this bill is as much about
changes in residency status as it is
about ensuring transients are taken care
of
and if I further know our laws already
speak to how the cost for transients
paid for one town are to be recovered
from the town where that trans transient
currently resides and finally Mr Speaker
if I know this bill confuses and
complicates the issue rather than
clarifies an already clear existing
statute
would I now press the red button so
another motion can be made thank you Mr
Speaker
representative Gilman is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that all
municipalities are required to assist
persons in need but have varying
capacity for that responsibility and
thus request the assistance of
surrounding communities with no mention
of costs involved and if I know that SB
110 clarifies the legal Municipal
residency of people who have been
released from incarceration
hospitalization or short-term assistance
program
and if I know this bill requires rather
than suggests Municipal welfare officers
to coordinate care and costs so that no
one Community takes an unequal burden
for the needs of a resident from any New
Hampshire municipality
would I then press the green button to
support Equitable Municipal
responsibility for emergency Quality of
Life Care
the questions on the motion about to
pass on sb110 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppose press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
representative smart
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend the state of the
vote
190 in the affirmative 180 in the
negative the Motions adopted
thank you
the committee on Municipal and County
governments which was referred to Senate
Bill 132 FN
prohibiting cities and towns from
adopting Sanctuary policies comes to us
without recommendation
for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion Mr Speaker
motion I moved to table
SB 132.
and I request a division vote
Representatives Davis moves uh Senate
Bill 132 be laid on the table
representative Lynn circuit requests of
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
the question is whether to lay Senate
Bill 132 on the table and this is a roll
call vote
representative Davis is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill in
some form or fashion has come before the
house at least three times in the past
and each time we have seen fit to defeat
or table it
whatever party held the majority
and we did that because it is an
improper imposition of federal law onto
our communities where citizens elect
officials to represent their interests
not to do Washington's bidding
and if I know that this bill represents
a sweeping prohibition against
implementing immigration policies
promulgated by the state on behalf of
the federal government and it's an
abrogation of local control
and if I also know that in this instant
it makes our citizens who serve in local
government at risk of Investigations and
lawsuits over the very words they speak
or the informal actions they take and if
I know that the costs of those lawsuits
will be borne by taxpayers would I not
press the green button and support the
tabling motion thank you Mr Speaker
representative Len circus recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker
if I know that our state needs to
promote Law and Order when the federal
government fails to do so and if I also
realize that our towns and cities and
the law enforcement agencies of those
municipalities should never impede the
apprehension
of detained criminal aliens
by immigration and custom enforcement by
intentionally employing policies that do
just that impede and finally and most
importantly if I know that this issue
has been
misrepresented by many individuals and
parties would I now press the red button
so the floor debates on the amendment
and the main motion can get a full
airing thank you Mr Speaker
the question is whether lay sp-132 on
the table and this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
thank you
[Music]
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attended the state of the
vote
203 and the affirmative 168 and the
negative Senate Bill 132 was laid on the
table
the committee on resources Recreation
and development so which was referred
Senate Bill 60 an act relative to water
quality having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendments and the recommendation that
the bill at you passed with Amendment
representative Suzanne Vale for the
committee
the committee amendment is one six three
five H Princeton House record two pages
30 to 32.
question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those proposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the Bill's on second reading and open to
further Amendment
representative Hines moves floor
Amendment one eight four zero H
Princeton House record 27 on pages 32-34
thank you
represent Heinz is recognized speak to
his Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker this is a Christmas
tree bill for marijuana legalization
that the house already passed
overwhelmingly so I'm asking that we put
it on something that the Senate
overwhelmingly wants now that the
coroner office has taken a slightly
different position on marijuana maybe
that will lead to the people on the
other side also flip-flopping so I asked
for your support it's legalized
marijuana thank you
representative Vale has recognized
against the amendment
I rise in opposition to Amendment 1848
as this is an attempt to keep a live
language related to cannabis that the
other body will never concur with and
for that reason please vote no on
Amendment 1840 H so that we can vote on
the bill as amended by the committee it
is an important Bill thank you so much
the question is on Amendment one eight
four zero H are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the Nays have it and the amendment fails
the question now is on the motion of
ought to pass on Senate bill
60.
are you ready for the question
although in favor say aye
all those opposed names
[Music]
the eyes have it and the report is
adopted
okay same thing
the committee on resources Recreation
and development to which was referred
Senate Bill 160 FN an act relative to
the use of ohrvs on designated trails
and requiring a permit to operate
certain ohrvs from Before Sunrise to
after Sunset having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendments on the recommendation at the
bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Suzanne's bail for the
committee the committee amendment is
1519 H Princeton announced record 27 on
page 46. the questions on the amendment
be ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the Irish habit and the Amendments
adopted the Bill's on second reading and
open a further Amendment representative
Heinz Ms floor Amendment one eight two
five-h Princeton House record 27 on
pages 46 to 47 and is recognized to
speak to his Amendment
thank you Mr Speaker this is attaching
another bill that the house passed this
one related to our self-defense
um so I ask that you support my
amendment that repeals the prohibition
on brass knuckles and blackjacks I think
if we have a right to self-defense of
lethal Force we also have the right to
self-defense for non-lethal Force so I
ask that you support our Second
Amendment rights and support the
amendment thank you
representative Muse is recognized to
speak against the amendment
thank you Mr Speaker
the amendment now before us would end
our state's current prohibition on
carrying or possessing with the intent
to sell Blackjack brass knuckles and
slung shots
um
we've been here before
and I know that there are always things
that we can do to try to make a good
bill and even better build
but passing this amendment is not one of
them
this particular amendment has been
opposed by the New Hampshire State
Police as well as by the New Hampshire
Chiefs of Police Association and it's
being opposed for a very good reason
if this policy were put into place it
not only would jeopardize the safety of
Law Enforcement Officers it would also
jeopardize the safety of the students in
our schools
anyone who goes into a bar or any type
of public accommodation and basically
any person walking down the street
so please please join with our law
enforcement community in opposing this
unnecessary and harmful change to a very
very good bill that really does deserve
to pass thank you
the question is on floor Amendment one
eight two five-h are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
Elizabeth
and the amendment fails
question now is on
the adoption of UTSA pass with
amendments on Senate Bill 60. are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the reports adopted
foreign
the committee on science technology and
energy to which is referred Senate Bill
54 FM
an act relative to purchased power
agreements for electric distribution
utilities having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation at the
bill ought to you pass with Amendment
representative Michael votes for the
committee the committee amendment is
1586-h Princeton announced record 27 on
pages 27-28 question is on the committee
Amendment you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye all those opposed
nay
the eyes have it
and the amendment's about
the bill is on second reading and open a
further Amendment
representative McGee move's floor
Amendment
1652h printed on house record 27 on page
28. representative Vos has recognized to
speak in support of the amendment
thank you Mr Speaker
the committee amendment that we just
adopted implemented eight of the nine
changes that our committee wanted to
make to the Senate bill 54.
the ninth change got lost somewhere
between our committee room and OLS
so this floor Amendment implements that
ninth change
if you look on page 27 of your calendar
down near the bottom of the page you'll
see a definition for new electric energy
sources
and you'll note that at the end of that
sentence is the phrase at a site where
no facility previously existed
then if you turn the page to page 28 and
you look at the floor Amendment
you'll discover that that phrase has
been eliminated
from that sentence
that's important because
Senate Bill 54
allows utilities to implement purchase
power agreements with newly constructed
energy sources
but without this amendment it would
prohibit
an injury Source that's built on a site
of an existing energy source
to be considered
so for example the Merrimack station
coal plant and bow if that was torn down
and replaced with a solar facility that
solar facility wouldn't be eligible
to participate in these ppas under
Senate Bill 54 unless this phrase is
removed
therefore we ask you to pass this floor
Amendment and then pass Senate Bill 54.
thank you Mr Speaker
the questions on the adoption of
amendment
1652-h are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted
the question now is on the motion of
oxapass as amended on Senate bill 54.
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye all those opposed nay
all right then the eyes have it
and the report is adopted
the committee on the special committee
on child care to which was referred
Senate Bill 94 an act relative to
residential child care licensing of
child care institutions and agencies
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation at the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative
Rebecca McWilliams for the committee
the amendment is
1810h President house record 27 on page
39. questions on the adoption of the
amendment you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye aye all those
opposed name the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted
representative McWilliams has requested
a division vote this will be a division
vote on Ocho pass as amended members
please take your seats
thank you
the questions on the adoption about your
past is amended on Senate Bill 94 this
is a division vote representative
McWilliams is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
special committee on Child Care is
dedicated to the task at hand and we are
passing two bills to Child Care bills
today
and I know that this is a very important
one and Mr Speaker if I also know that
the house special committee on child
care has been doing listening sessions
across the state having recently
completed one in Conway
and planning to have another one on the
Seacoast shortly for you to report to
your constituents
and if I further know that this bill as
amended was unanimously supported out of
committee and modernizes several of the
terminology definitions that we use for
child care in New Hampshire for the 21st
century would I then press the green
button to support this unanimous
positive move in the right direction for
child care in New Hampshire thank you Mr
Speaker
the question is ought to pass as amended
on Senate Bill 94 this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
foreign
members presence had an opportunity to
vote
the house will attended the state of the
329 in the affirmative 34 in the
negative the reports adopted
foreign
[Music]
the majority committee on transportation
to which was referred Senate Bill 118 FN
an act requiring children under the age
of two years to be strained in a motor
vehicle having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative George Sykes for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same in being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the following
resolution that it is inexpediate to
legislate representative Ted Gorski for
the minority of the committee chair
recognizes representative Leon
thank you madam chair I rise today in
opposition to the ought to pass motion
on its Senate bill 118. this bill would
change our current car seat law which
requires children under the age of seven
and under the height of four feet nine
inches to be restrained in a motor
vehicle and when add the requirement
that under the age of two they would be
rear-facing regardless of their size the
weight or the manufacturer requirements
of the seat
proponents of this bill believe that
children under two being in a rare
rear-facing car seat is an easy way to
increase child safety but they don't
realize the unintended consequences
the two biggest problems here are that
this law will tell parents that when
their child turns two it's time to turn
them forward-facing and there's also the
problem of car seats that will not fit
into the vehicle
so car seats have changed a lot since
many of you have had car seats and
they've changed in the 11 years that
I've been in the market
they're a lot easier to install and as
the move towards extended rear-facing
happens they're getting bigger and
bigger it's great for safety but it's
not so good for families with small cars
I have a giant sequoia SUV and a midsize
sedan with my third car child it was
very very hard to find an infant car
seat that would fit in the sedan with
all five members of the family
it was absolutely impossible to find a
larger rear-facing seat onesie sized out
of the baby seat that would allow us all
to sit in the car that meant we took two
cars for some families that means you
need to buy a second vehicle or buy a
new vehicle because you can't all fit in
the car
so while there's organizations that will
provide a rear-facing car seat for
families there's no organizations that
help you get a new car if you don't fit
so the biggest problem here is saying
that the age at age two you can turn
your child forward-facing
last session we saw a bill like this
that turned into a study committee
I was on that committee along with the
prime sponsor of this bill we had a lot
of experts that came in and testified to
us and you might be surprised to know
but each one of you would be safer if
you were riding in a car we are facing
every single one of you would be safer
except the driver wouldn't be able to
see the road
so as we look at this we also had
documentation of what happens in car
accidents in New Hampshire especially
with children under age too
96 percent of Granite State children in
the last two years involved in traffic
accidents were in rear-facing car seats
that means four percent weren't
following what would be law
the state police testified that they're
doing a great job when they get seven
percent compliance so this is quite
honestly not necessary and even worse
it's harmful right now if you ask your
pediatrician how long to keep your child
rear-facing the answer is as long as you
can having three and four-year-olds
rear-facing is safest and if you can do
it you should
the problem is
you hit your second birthday you turn
forward facing and you lose that safety
on those three and four-year-olds that
otherwise would stay in a rear-facing
seat we do actually have some junior
members here in the infant car seats
because some people will tell you that
you come home from the hospital we're
facing I can pretty much guarantee you
that a year from now neither of them
will fit into those infant seats and
they may need to purchase another
rear-facing seat by then
so there's a lot of unintended
consequences and parents are already
keeping their children rear-facing if
they can this is unnecessary potentially
harmful and I ask for you to overturn
this motion so that a better motion can
be made thank you with a member yield
for a question
the member yields
thank you madam speaker I feel much more
comfortable doing this backwards
I've heard the most most parents who go
to these uh these Cosi check stations uh
or things with the the fire department
and the police have their car seats
installed backwards or wrong or whatever
how can we possibly expect to trust
parents with this
well thank you for the question
um there actually was a testimony in
committee that over 90 percent of people
at the car check stations did not have
them installed correctly but that's
because most people can figure it out
and if you don't there are lots of
advertised places for car seat
Specialists to help you make sure it's
right
we should applaud these parents they had
a question they got it fixed and now
their kids are safe and that's not
really a good data point
with the member yield for a second
question the member does yields
thank you for taking my question is it
not true that young children have weaker
necks much bigger heads and skulls that
have not fused
thank you for the question yes a
newborn's head is 25 of its weight and
for us it's six percent of our weight
and children's necks don't are hyper
mobile all the way through their teens
you don't even close all of your skull
Searchers until you reach your 20s
that's a good reason why we should keep
the law the way it is which encourages
parents to keep their children
rear-facing as long as possible instead
of telling them that it's safe to turn
them forward facing at two years
with a member yield for a third question
thank you the member yields
thank you
um I have spoken to parents and I'm
wondering if in this bill there's any
exception for extenuating circumstances
I had a mom who had a torn esophagus and
for her maneuvering
um to she couldn't physically pull her
child out from the rear-facing position
because the setup of her car in the seat
in this situation would there be any
exception for her she turned the seat
around temporarily until her esophagus
healed and then
um put it back where you're facing is
there any exception for something like
that
um thank you for the question there is
no exception for that or any other
reason
would the member yield for a fourth
question the member yields this will be
the final question
thank you
if we pass this bill how will we compare
to other states
thank you very much for the question my
data is from last year's study committee
last year we were one of 30 States that
had no law on rear-facing there was
there are two states
sorry there's nine states that require
children under one to be rear-facing but
eight of those allow a certain if
they're over 20 pounds to move to
forward facing there are 13 states that
require children under two to be
rear-facing but if they're too tall too
heavy or they're outside manufacturer
guidelines then they can move forward
facing if we pass this will be one of
five states even more restrictive than
California that don't even have a weight
limit or a height limit I think we
should trust to The Experts that say
rear face as long as possible and Trust
the parents and vote this down thank you
the chair recognizes representative
Rambo
thank you madam speaker Madam speaker I
rise today in support of the house
Transportation majority recommendation
of ought to pass for SB 118. SB 118
calls for children under the age of two
years old to be restrained in a
rear-facing child car seat in motor
vehicle the bill seeks to keep children
under the age of two-year-olds safer
when traveling in a vehicle in the event
of a collision
it includes an exception for children
under age two who exceed the relevant
wait minimums
if you've left the hospital as a parent
with the newborn in recent years you may
remember Hospital staff ensuring that
you had safely secured your baby in a
rear-facing seat before allowing you to
drive home
that's because the medical and
scientific Community consensus is clear
the mechanical engineering and physics
of rear-facing car seats make it Far and
Away the safest way to travel by car for
children ages zero to two
rear-facing car seats ensure adequate
time for children to develop and using
the correct car seat can reduce injuries
and death
a newborn's head makes up about 25
percent of its body weight
the younger a child is the less form the
neck muscles
most accidents are forward moving
collisions making it crucial to protect
a newborn's neck and skull upon impact
as the Brain Injury Association of
America has noted the symptoms of brain
injury in children may be similar to
those experienced by an adult but the
functional impact can be very different
the cognitive impairments of a child
with a brain injury may not be
immediately obvious after the injury it
may only become apparent as the child
gets older
majority of parents do use the use these
for their newborns and infants for some
period of time
around rear-facing car seats with
uniformity Beyond leaving the hospital
requires education and inform
enforcement as well as engineering
accordingly multiple non-profit agencies
concerned with these safety issues
testified in Committee in favor of this
bill Dartmouth Health AAA in the
American Academy of Pediatrics all
support rear-facing car seats for
children
younger children this bill would not
overlap with existing laws in New
Hampshire dozens of experts legislators
and citizens including parents have
expressed their support for this bill in
hearings not a single group or
individual contested the safety aspect
of this bill
rear-facing car seats are not more
expensive than front-facing car seats
which are already required by law for
this age group in fact convertible car
seats can be cost Savers because they
can face backwards for the first two
years and then be face forward to
accommodate a larger weight and age
range thus lasting longer in addition
Dartmouth health is committed to
providing rear-facing car seats for
families in need
one child injury is too many if we can
prevent that injury we should try we
often talk about weighing whether
proposed safety legislation imposes too
great a burden or restriction on an
individual's autonomy this bill does not
interfere with a child's ability to
engage in any activity you would
otherwise have available
to the contrary it preserves our
children's chances to walk and run and
live their most active lives going
forward this bill will help protect our
most vulnerable passengers their arter
required to be restrained in a car seat
at this age this bill simply calls for
the safe position safest positioning
brain injury prevention is responsible
Common Sense public policy while this
legislation was voted down on the other
side of the wall the last time it came
up in 2021 has now been passed by a
Voice vote by the other body I ask that
you vote to keep our newborns and
infants safe on our roads and to provide
our families with the legal enforcement
framework to do the same I ask you to
support the majority recommendation of
OTP on SB 118 and push the green button
so that sb-18 may pass thank you madam
speaker and I would request a division
vote please
question before the house is the ought
to pass motion on Senate Bill 118 a
division vote has been requested this
will be a division vote
thank you
question before us is on the automash
motion on Senate Bill 118 this will be a
division vote members please take their
seats
chair recognizes representative Gorski
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker
Madam speaker if I know that today when
a parent asks their pediatrician how
long did she keep their child
rear-facing the right answer is as long
as you can
and if I know that this bill if this
bill passes the answer will be
you can turn your child forward facing
when they turn two
would I then in the interest of child
safety press the red button so a more
appropriate motion can be made
chair recognizes representative Crawford
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker Madam speaker if
I know that this bill fills a much
needed Gap in child safety and if I know
that this bill does not overlap any
other existing law and has tremendous
bipartisan support and was passed
unanimously by the chamber behind us
and if I know that car crashes are the
leading cause of death for children ages
1 through 13. and Madam speaker if I
know the chiefs of police New Hampshire
highway safety Brain Injury Association
Triple A Dartmouth Hitchcock and Concord
Pediatrics all support this bill then
Madam speaker would I now vote to
support this bill and protect those who
cannot protect themselves and agree with
the committee report of ought to pass by
pushing the green Bud thank you madam
speaker
the question before us is on ought to
pass on Senate Bill 118 this will be a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
with 192 in the affirmative 173 in the
negative the ought to pass motion passes
the majority of the committee on
transportation to which was referred
Senate Bill 256 FN an act establishing a
safety program for off Highway
recreational vehicles having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative
Daniel vayu for the majority of the
commitment
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report that the
following resolution that is inexpedient
to legislate representative Ted Gorski
for the minority of the committee
question before us is on the amendment
1578 printed in House Records set 27 on
page 52.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the emotion is
adopted
question before us now is ought to pass
as amended and the chair recognizes
representative Gorski
thank you madam speaker
I stand in opposition to SB 256.
now Madam speaker
when I think about this bill
it reminds me of the National Football
League
and you may ask how does it relate to
that well many years ago the National
Football League also stood for the no
fund League
and when I think of this bill I look at
it as the no fund bill
now why the NFL was cracking down was it
we're cracking down on celebrations in
terms of having fun
and this is exactly what this bill does
this bill legislates fun
now how does it do it well we're talking
about off Highway
recreational vehicles
so you may be asking yourself well what
is an off Highway recreational vehicle
well according to the definition
it is used in a public way for a
pleasure or recreational purposes
it runs on rubber tires tracks or
cushion of air
it depends on the ground or other
surface for travel
and lastly has an operator
who sits on the vehicle
now Madam speaker if this bill passes
one of the things it requires is that
all various individuals will need to
attend five hours of training
to from these vehicles
talk about legislation of fun
George Bernard shura once said we don't
stop playing because we grow old we grow
old because we stop playing
if this law passes it could also have a
negative impact to our New Hampshire
recreational industry
so I ask you pressing the red button is
a vote for fun
so I ask you to vote for fun so we can
itl this bill so a new motion can be
made thank you madam speaker
the chair recognizes representative
thank you madam speaker
colleagues I Rise to speak in support of
sp256 which establishes a safety
certification program for off Highway
recreational vehicles or ohrvs
which include ATVs altering vehicles
all utility terrain vehicles or utvs
side by sides and Gators
this program will only apply to
recreational uses of ohrvs operators who
work on farms or on construction sites
will be exempt from this program
this bill has been referred to as the no
fund bill
I like to refer to it as the fund
preservation bill
be two levels
there'll be two levels of certification
the temporary certificate issued for
anybody who wants to rent
an ohrv on a temporary basis
and a lifetime certification which may
be issued after completion of a more
in-depth training course
ohrvs have become extremely popular in
New Hampshire especially in the North
country where they have become an
important part of the local economy
contributing an estimated 300 million
dollars
and nearly 2 500 jobs in 2020 alone
while ohrvs are primarily operated
off-road and established Trails they are
increasingly allowed on State and local
roadways giving Riders access to gas
stations restaurants lodging and other
amenities where they support local
businesses the proposed safety
certification program seeks to address
some major areas of concern that have
Arisen as the sports popularity as has
grown firstly many of the trails these
vehicles use Traverse private property
with the permission of landowners as
more operators take advantage of the
sport
cases have increased where Riders have
deviated from the established Trails
trespassed on private land and caused
significant property damage to Farms
woodlands and wetlands consequently many
landowners have become hesitant to allow
access to Trails which poses a threat to
the sport and local economies that have
become to rely on it
a comprehensive safety certification
program aims to represerve good
relationships with landowners by
informing operators about these concerns
and educating them on responsible
ridership and the importance of
following proper Trail etiquette
secondly ohrvs
as whicheveries some of which are as big
and powerful as cars are increasingly
allowed to operate on state state and
local highways safety training will also
also focus on participant
one second we'll also focus on educating
participants about the rules of the road
participants will be taught the specific
laws and regulations governing the use
of ohrvs on public roads ensuring they
understand their rights and
responsibilities as operators they will
learn about speed limits
traffic signs signaling reducing excess
noise as they drive through
neighborhoods and other crucial aspects
of safe courteous operation additionally
participants will receive guidance on
sharing the road with other vehicles
following proper lane discipline and
practicing Defensive Driving techniques
lastly ohrb safety training will cover
the physical risk and limitations of
these vehicles when operating on paved
roadways
these can include things that people who
have been writing for their entire lives
may not be aware of participants will
learn about the unique characteristics
of ohrvs such as their size weight and
handling capabilities and how these
factors affect their operational paved
roadways versus dirt trails tires
designed for off-road conditions May
perform very differently on paved
roadways affecting steering acceleration
and braking distances operators will be
educated about the importance of
understanding turning radius and
maneuvering limitations specific to HR
ohrvs by understanding the physical
risks and limitations of their vehicles
participants can make informed decisions
while operating on roadways adjusting
their driving behavior
to ensure their safety and the safety of
others
or they will risk losing their their
certificate
as they would their driver's license
this knowledge empowers participants
even those who have been may have been
operating for decades to make
responsible choices in Adaptive Driving
style according to the capabilities and
limitations of their ohrvs reducing the
risk of damage to private property
preventing accidents and promoting safer
Road usage
thank you madam speaker with the member
yield for a question
no I will not the member does not yield
the question before us is on the
question of ought to pass is amended on
Senate Bill 256. are you ready for the
question
the division vote has been requested
this will be a division vote members
please take their seats
roll call has been requested by
representative Ammon has that been
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members will please
take their seats
thank you
the house will come to order the chair
recognizes representative gorsky for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker
if I know that this bill will require
five-hour training course for many of
our constituents who want to write an
ohrv
and if I know that this bill this no
fund bill could have a negative impact
on New Hampshire's recreational industry
would I then in the interest of fund
press the red button so a more
appropriate motion can be made
the chair recognizes representative
Sykes for parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker
Madam speaker
if I know that this is a bill
so I'm having
a new eyeglass issues I apologize about
that if I know that the popularity of
ohrvs has surged in New Hampshire
particularly in the North country where
it has become one of the Mainstays of
its economy
and if I also know that ohrvs
are powerful motor vehicles that are
primarily operated off-road but also do
operate on established roads
and one way to help improve the
maintenance and preservation of trails
is to have people who are trained
on how to operate those Vehicles keeping
more private land available for trails
and finally and most importantly that
if I know ohrvs are due in fact
increasingly operate on roadways and
it's critical to ensure that the
operators are aware of the rules of the
road
as well as the performance limitation of
their vehicles many of these that got
rented
come right
right as part of that rental agreement
they're told that they should not
operate this particular vehicle because
of its tires on hard pavement but many
people don't realize that and training
program will help establish that
thank you madam speaker and
what I now press the green button to
support the majority committee report
question before us is all that auto pass
is amended motion on Senate bill 256.
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are now open for
30 seconds
have all members present had the
opportunity to vote the house will tend
to the state of the vote
with 186 in the affirmative 179 and the
negative the motion passes
the house will come to order
the committee on ways to me which was
referred Senate Bill 49 FN an act
relative to creating a dedicated
non-lapsing fund and a biennial report
of such fund for oplc having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Jordan ullery for
the committee are you ready for the
question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed say nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted
house will now attend to the Bill's
removed from consent
a committee on Election law to which was
referred cacr-9 an act relating to the
New Hampshire presidential primary
providing that New Hampshire
presidential primary will be the first
presidential primary but presidential
election cycle and considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution result that is inexpeding to
legislate senator rossbury for the
committee
for what purpose to memorize
motion Mr Speaker
stage of motion
I moved to lay cacr9 on the table
there's a proper motion
who
did somebody request the Roll Call
is that sufficiently seconded
no it's not sufficiently seconded
the motion before us is table cacr9 are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
[Applause]
those opposed nay
I think it's been put on the table
committee on executive departments and
administration to which was referred
Senate Bill 107 act relative to General
administration of regulatory boards and
commissions considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with Amendment Senator Tony
Lucas for the committee the amendment is
2012 h
inton in house record 27 pages 39
through 45. are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye those opposed nay
guys have it and the amendment is
adopted
bills on second reading open to Fleur of
their Amendment
the
its floor Amendment
2075h printed and I'll track it 27 pages
45-46.
the chair recognizes representative
Carol McGuire
thank you Mr Speaker
as everybody in Edna and maybe one or
two others know as well this year we
completely re-codified the statute
governing the office of professional
licensure and certification we took took
it out of one RSA and moved it into a
new one
with and major revisions at the same
time
that's fine except that we also had a
whole bunch of other bills that affected
other licensing statutes that referred
to
the
the oplc statute and they couldn't refer
to the correct new statute because it
didn't exist yet
it refers to the old statute but we
still don't want to ignore those items
so this
amendment gives the enrolled bills
committee and OLS the authority to say
oh this is an oplc Bill instead of going
to this RSA which doesn't exist anymore
we put it in the new one it is purely to
allow them to take care of this
mechanical process and keep us from
having a whole slew of bills next year
to do it ourselves so I and since I
would be dealing with it next year I
simply hope you will support this
amendment thank you
motion before us is floor Amendment
2075h are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
the eyes have it and the floor amendment
is adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with Amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
foreign
committee motion amendment is adopted
the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne for the
third reading motion hey Mr Speaker
resolved that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time at the reading of bills be
by title only and resolutions by caption
only and that all bills ordered a third
reading be read a third time by this
resolution and that all titles of bills
be the same as adopted and that they be
passed at the present time and when the
house adjourns today it be to meet
Thursday June 15th at 10 A.M that's my
birthday thank you
we still got something to do
the question is on the third reading
motion I the house will be in order
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it the motion is adopted
the house will attend to announcements
share recognize representative D Simone
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker today the owls met
thank you
and we decided to meet again next week
at lunchtime in the Webster room and
this will be an organizational meeting
we need Republicans and Democrats to
come to the next meeting so that we can
elect a president vice president and so
forth down the line it's a great group
please join us men and women thank you
go ahead the house will be in order
you
thank you Mr speaker thank
you I just wanted to remind everyone
about the legislative Golf Classic
which will be held Monday June 26th
starting at 8 30 a.m at Loudoun Country
Club shotgun start shotgun shotgun
we've had a lot of folks sign up already
but there's still plenty of room for
those who want to sign up
there will be lots of raffle prizes and
prizes for the top golf teams as well
and special contests longest drive
nearest the pin straightest Drive best
looking golfer
best looking golfer what just kidding
rep turcott already has been selected
for that award and we have two wrapped
haircuts so that's
what was that we have two rep tour cots
one on the left one on the right we
let's let's recognize them both sure
um do we also have some people
sponsoring holes
oh I'm sorry I went off script and I got
sidetracked okay uh yes we have
Senator Pearl
representing hole 17. he's for district
17. and I think representative Bert cell
said that there might be a sponsorship
of the 19th hole
I believe the beer caucus is sponsoring
the 19th hole that's the way it should
be
but there is a nice payoff if you make
the hole in one sink the shot and you
can win twenty thousand dollars which
could buy you a used pickup truck
or a used Prius
uh but more good news there will be a
hole in one prize at the other three par
threes as well uh thank you
representative infantine for setting
everything up for us we appreciate it
great raffle prizes as well a 50 50
raffle a putting contest which will be
run by two of our favorite lobbyists
yes and if you you don't have to be a
registered golfer to participate in the
putting contest to show up with a five
dollar bill
if you're not a golfer you can still
come to the Social and mix and mingle
not only with talented lawmakers but
also with big time influencers and maybe
a super secret special guest if you're
not an early riser you can still come to
the social for only twenty dollars but
think about buying some raffle tickets
but if you also can bring some campaign
signs to place around the course you can
do that and if you don't have any
campaign sites you can recycle any old
ones you may have in storage like for
Mitt Romney or Hillary Clinton
sorry I lost my I lost track too many
papers
[Laughter]
knowing that a few of our members have
been known to take a libation under
extreme social pressure be advised that
the beer cart will indeed be on the Move
throughout the day with some familiar
faces riding shotgun shotgun again
shotgun again
serving as a roving Ranger in a separate
cart will be representative Jess Edwards
thank you very much his job will be to
provide security and keep things moving
in the interest of equity and diversity
he will be assisted by a female member
of the other party who doesn't mind his
cigar smoke
[Laughter]
great teams
get it
and a team by with Raph Hill and rep
Walsh for diversity a woman named Amy
mayo and another great team will be the
team four kids that's
f-o-r-e for those golfers out there get
it it includes education committee
stalwarts representative Miler and
representative Ludo and for diversity it
also features representative Tanner and
The Honorable Sue Mullen now nice
oh so we're already off to a good start
in terms of registrations we have about
20 I think about 25
but we do want to have a good time while
supporting a good cause which would be
again Manchester's Liberty house which
helps homeless and transitioning
veterans
oh wait did I leave you skipped the
whole part I
[Laughter]
did so he was going to say don't worry
we'll have same-day registrations I say
no we don't want same-day registrations
but we do want to have a good time while
supporting a good cause which would be
Manchester's Liberty house
go ahead finish it off rep magliar and
then I'll say it's a good cause of deed
for more information you can represent
myself I'd represent you can contact
myself representative Moffett also
thank you we look forward to seeing you
all on Monday June 26th at Loudoun
Country Club thank you Mr speaker thank
you Mr speaker thank you Mr Clark
Jr recognizes the clerk
this won't be nearly as exciting
committee chairs please come see me
before you leave today to go over house
bills amended by the Senate please come
up to the office or call me tomorrow if
you want to form Committees of
conference we will be able to do that in
recess uh otherwise you do need to get
your reports back for next week's
session so please do come see me after
session upstairs or call me tomorrow
also please empty your seat pockets and
your mailboxes in the back there have
been things growing out of some of the
mailboxes in the back and we encourage
you to please empty them thank you
chair recognize representative Moulton
for unanimous consent
thank you Mr Speaker
I wanted to publicly praise another
member of this house I'm not sure if he
is still here or if he's stepped out
Representative Steve Peterson
did he leave
he left okay well that's a shame but oh
he is here all right can you come
forward Representative no okay well I
was in a severe car accident
and he was the first responder who came
to my Aid he did an excellent job and I
think he deserves a round of applause
[Applause]
thank you
I was just as
first of all I don't I don't
secondly I was just a surprise to see
your face when I crawled through the
passenger side of that car
as you were to see mine so
um
regardless I just I still feel that you
did a good job and you treated me with
compassion and I just felt that it would
be appropriate to give you public
recognition for it all right thank you
[Music]
sure recognized representative Horrigan
for a unanimous consent
my speech is a
my speech is uh short I'll make it even
shorter I was uh we've had a good day
today a lot of bipartisanship and I
certainly don't want to
want to ruin that in any way but it's
just there's a historical marker 278 was
put up uh well last month on May 1st and
then taken down two weeks later which
honored a woman named Elizabeth Gurley
Flynn also known as the rebel girl and
um
I think certainly she there are some
things uh there's some things she did
which people don't agree with now but uh
you know for the most part she was a
remarkable person and she agrees uh I
think she deserved the uh historical
marker it would have been um well she
lived at 12 Montgomery Street which is
not far from the state house and that
her house doesn't exist anymore but they
put it on the edge of the parking lot of
the Merrimack Valley courthouse and um
and actually some unofficial signs were
sprung up there so she's probably
getting more attention than she would
have gotten if they just left it up
there and um
she also happened her family happened to
be a neighbor of Mary Baker Eddie the
founder of Christian Science whose
historical marker is still standing and
I certainly think uh Christian Science
it's probably an outmoded uh I apologize
any Christian Scientist that was an
outmoded uh means of health of a health
care and probably the particular
political
um parties you belonged to also had what
are now outmoded ideas about politics
and how to organize an economy but
I think the markers still still should
be put up if not uh on the courthouse
but somewhere so
um I'll uh
that's probably more day what do they
need to say about it but I think that
was uh just sort of unfair not everybody
who has an historical marker is perfect
and she served it and certainly none of
us are perfect so I would
that's a I'd like to urge you to say
that and I probably will
I don't know how far to go but I think
it will be exploring some way to have a
resolution or a bill or something to
address that issue at some point in the
future so thanks Tim congratulations to
uh you Mr Speaker and our leadership for
getting the budget over the line uh so
easily it was uh definitely I've been
through eight budgets and that's
definitely the best budget uh by far
that we at least the best budget process
we've had by far so thanks
Garrett
care recognizes representative Perez
thank you Mr Speaker and members of the
House
I'm raising today to say thank you to
everyone who respect me for who I am
many of you know English is not my first
language
many times I've been told that people
don't understand when I'm speaking
I'm very sorry
I try my best
to speak clearance as I can
and I'm here to tell
not just the Democrats and Republicans
thank you for those who
respect me and work with me and show me
that I'm another state representative
who's here to represent their
constituents
but I'm very disappointed
very disappointed
with people from my own party today
after I make a statement that I would
not support the budget because there
were certain things in the budget that I
don't
personally believe or respect
I was approached by people on my own
body and told me that I'm one issue
state representative
which I'm not
I'm asking
not just Democrats and Republicans
but I work with both sides of the aisle
with many issues
not just here in the state halls but
with the Hillsborough County
I try to work with everyone
I feel very disappointed because I show
it everywhere and some of the people who
call me out today and told me that I'm
just one issue person
I want them to told me where you been
when I show up not just a Milford but
everywhere in the state
support a new community when you're not
there
please tell me where you've been and you
can come in and told me that I'm just
one issue person
I want you to tell me you fit in my face
where have you been
when I spend hours and hours on my day
supporting new constituents when you're
not there
I want you to tell me
how can you ask me to support issues
that you care
but when I ask you to support something
you call me out
like I'm not a human or like I don't oh
my community don't don't even matter
I'm asking you
show me your respect
don't show the respect only when you
need the ball from my community show
them every day
every day of the year thank you so much
[Applause]
representative Wiseman moved at the
house stand in recess for the purpose of
the introduction of bills and World
build amendments and Road Bill reports
receiving message informing committees
at conference are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes the eyes have
it
and the motion is adopted the house is
in recess until Thursday June 15 2023 at
10 A.M